The first Conservative Party conference I attended was in 1946. You will understand I know the humility I feel, at following in the footsteps of great men like our leader that year, Winston Churchill, oh, a man called by destiny who raised the name of Britain to supreme heights in the history of the free world. We are coming, I think, to yet another turning point in our long history. We can go on as we have been going and continue down, or we can stop, and with a decisive act of will, we can say enough.
我参加的第一次保守党大会是在1946年。你们会理解，追随像我们那年的领袖温斯顿·丘吉尔这样伟大人物的脚步，我感到多么谦卑。哦，那是一位被命运召唤的人，他在自由世界的历史上将英国的名声提升到了至高无上的高度。我想，我们正处于漫长历史中的又一个转折点。我们可以像过去那样继续走下去，继续衰落，或者我们可以停下来，以一种果断的意志行动，说一声“够了”。
Let us, all of us here today and others far beyond this hall, who believe in our cause, make that act of will. Let us proclaim our faith in a new and better future for our party and our people. Let us resolve to heal the wounds of a divided nation, and let that act of healing be the prelude to a lasting thing. So that was Margaret Thatcher and it was her first speech to the Conservative Party Conference as leader and she delivered it on the 10th of October 1975 and astute listeners will have recognised that Mrs Thatcher there did not sound like she did later with her deep masculine voice and her slow, steady elocution because at this point she hadn't actually had the elocution lessons that gave her that voice. At this point, and I I think I'm right, anti-Dominic, in saying this, she had a much shriller, faster, less controlled voice. And so through the medium of vocal impression, I have conveyed the transformation that was to come later in Mrs. Satchez's career. Do you know why, I really take my hat off to you there, because I had anticipated you would do it in the husky voice. It had never occurred to me that you wouldn't, and you brought to it at a level of nuance that I had not anticipated.
让我们，今天在座的所有人，以及大厅之外那些相信我们事业的人，做出那种意志的行动。让我们为我们的党和我们的人民宣告我们对一个崭新而美好未来的信念。让我们下定决心治愈一个分裂国家的创伤，让这种治愈的行动成为持久事物的序曲。所以，那是玛格丽特·撒切尔，这是她作为领袖在1975年10月10日向保守党大会发表的第一次演讲。敏锐的听众会认出，那时的撒切尔夫人听起来并不像她后来那样，有着深沉的男性化嗓音和缓慢、平稳的演讲风格，因为在这一点上，她实际上还没有接受过赋予她那种声音的演讲训练。在这一点上，我想我是对的，反多米尼克，这样说吧，她的声音要尖锐得多，快得多，也更不受控制。因此，通过声音模仿的媒介，我传达了撒切尔夫人职业生涯后期将会发生的转变。你知道为什么吗？我真的向你脱帽致敬，因为我预料你会用那种沙哑的声音来表演。我从未想过你不会这样做，而且你赋予了它一种我未曾预料到的细微差别。
Thank you. And what makes that even better is actually I've got a really violent cold. So my my voice is naturally more deep than it is. And it's a great speech, isn't it? Because you've got complete Thatcher bingo there. You've got the invocation of Winston. You've got the patriotism. You've got the apocalyptic sense of national decline.
谢谢。让这一切变得更好的是，我其实患了非常严重的感冒。所以我的声音自然比平时更低沉。这是一场精彩的演讲，不是吗？因为你在这里得到了完整的“撒切尔宾果游戏”。你有对温斯顿的祈求。你有爱国主义。你有对国家衰落的末日感。
You've got the talk of faith. You've got the talk of healing, of victory. And that's what she is. This kind of colossal figure in whose shadow all of us who grew up through the late 70s and 80s spent our childhood and our youth. Yeah, you're not wrong. I mean, she became Tory leader when I was not yet one, and she left as Tory leader and Prime Minister when I was 16.
你有关于信仰的谈话。你有关于治愈、关于胜利的谈话。而这就是她。这是一个巨大的身影，我们这些在70年代末和80年代成长起来的人，都在她的阴影下度过了我们的童年和青年时代。是的，你没说错。我的意思是，她成为保守党领袖时我还没满一岁，而她卸任保守党领袖和首相时我16岁。
So she was there for a ridiculously long time. She was, as anybody knows, who grew up in Britain in those years, she was this sort of transcendent figure. Everybody had heard of her. Everybody knew what they thought of her. They either loved her by and large, or they absolutely hated her. The Marmite Prime Minister.
所以她在那里的时间长得离谱。正如任何在那些年里在英国长大的人所知，她是一个超越性的存在。每个人都听说过她。每个人都知道自己对她的看法。他们要么大体上爱她，要么绝对恨她。那个“马麦酱”式的首相。
more than Marmite. I mean, all the political and social changes of the 80s and 90s somehow came to be embodied in her or attributed to her, weren't they? So whatever happened, it was assumed that she had a finger in it in one way or another. Even if people hated her, they thought that she was doing things, that she was pulling levers and changes were being affected. And I suppose that is a massive contrast with the leaders that we have now. You're not wrong. where it doesn't matter who they are, they just come in, they're completely useless and nothing changes. Yeah, and the funny thing is it's a sign of how much her shadow endures, that of the Tory's recent leaders, you know, Theresa May basically tried to turn herself into a Thatcher tribute act. Liz Truss, you may remember when she was debating Rishi Sunak to try and become Tory leader, she actually dressed as Margaret Thatcher, put on a Thatcher costume, which is insane. And even today, Kemi Badock, people who are sort of trying to talk Kambi Badoop up will say,
比马麦酱还要多。我的意思是，80年代和90年代所有的政治和社会变革不知何故都体现在她身上，或者归因于她，不是吗？所以无论发生了什么，人们都认为她以某种方式插手了。即使人们恨她，他们也认为她在做事，她在操纵杠杆，变革正在发生。我想这与我们现在的领导人形成了巨大的对比。你没说错。无论他们是谁，这都不重要，他们只是上台，完全没用，什么都不会改变。是的，有趣的是，这标志着她的阴影有多么持久，在保守党最近的领导人中，你知道，特蕾莎·梅基本上试图把自己变成撒切尔的致敬表演。利兹·特拉斯，你可能记得当她与里希·苏纳克辩论以试图成为保守党领袖时，她实际上打扮成了玛格丽特·撒切尔，穿上了撒切尔的服装，这太疯狂了。即使在今天，凯米·巴德诺克，那些试图吹捧凯米·巴德诺克的人也会说，
Well, you know, Margaret Thatcher was poorly thought of when she was first leader to the opposition. Maybe she will change, you know, maybe it'll be the same story and all this kind of thing. I suppose, I mean, the comparison with Kemmy Bader Knaud is better than the previous two because Kemi Badernock has become leader as leader of the opposition, whereas May and trust became Prime Minister straight away. So that's kind of cheating. Yes. And in fact, you know, for people who are questioning the comparison, we're meeting
嗯，你知道，玛格丽特·撒切尔在刚担任反对党领袖时评价也很低。也许她会改变，你知道，也许会是同样的故事，诸如此类。我想，我的意思是，与凯米·巴德诺克的比较比前两位要好，因为凯米·巴德诺克是作为反对党领袖上台的，而梅和特拉斯是直接成为首相的。所以那有点作弊。是的。事实上，你知道，对于那些质疑这种比较的人，我们今天在撒切尔进入她那帝国般的辉煌之前就见到了她。很多人也看衰她。所以这就是今天这一集的故事，关于她在1975年2月如何成为第一位领导英国政党的女性。这也是关于70年代中期英国政治系列的第一集。所以这是英国现代史上一个绝对疯狂的时期。它延续了我们在2024年制作的关于1974年的系列节目。所以我们将见到一些老朋友，哈罗德·威尔逊，马西·威廉姆斯。那确实很疯狂。他提到了马西·威廉姆斯。所以那是首相哈罗德·威尔逊的助手们针对她的阴谋。
Thatcher today before she entered her imperial pomp. lot of people were writing her off too. And so this is the story in today's episode of how in February 1975 she becomes the first woman to lead the British political party. And it's also the first episode in the series on the politics of mid-70s Britain. So an absolutely bonkers period in kind of British modern history. And it's following on from a series who did in 2024, about the year in 1974. So we'll be meeting some old favourites, Harold Wilson, Marcy Williams. That really was bonkers. He mentioned Marcy Williams. So the plot to her by Prime Minister Harold Wilson's aides.
还有那个脱光衣服在地上打滚，尖叫着说我们都完了的金融家伙。所以威廉·阿姆斯特朗，他是公务员系统的负责人。他会出现吗？不，遗憾的是他没有出现。但还有其他一些疯子会出现。所以我们有大卫·鲍伊，当然还有性手枪乐队。所以那会非常令人兴奋。
And that financial bloke who took all his clothes off and rolled around on the floor, screaming that we were all doomed. So William Armstrong, he was the head of the civil service. Is he popping up? No, he's not puffing up, sadly. But there's some other, there's loads of mad people popping up. So we've got David Bowie and, of course, the sex pistols. So that's going to be very exciting.
那只是听众将不得不忍受的内容的一点点预告。天哪，这只是听众将不得不忍受的内容的预告。好吧。那么，在我们谈到撒切尔本人之前，先来设定一下背景。我们距离第二次世界大战结束已经25年了。英国赢得了那场战争。
That's a little taste of what this. Listeners all have to. Fuck, fuck, fuck. Oh God, this is a taste of what listeners will have to endure. All right. So let's set the scene before we get to Thatcher herself. So we are 25 years on from the end of the Second World War. Which Britain won.
英国确实赢了。我想，如果你想说得准确点，她说：“当其他所有人都投降时，我们独自站立。当欧洲处于锁链中时，我们拯救了半个欧洲。”我想那是直接引语。总之，英国是一个被改变的国家。英国失去了它的帝国。
Which Britain did win. I think the technical, if you want to get it right, she says, We stood alone when everyone else surrendered. We rescued half Europe. When Europe was in chains. That I think is the direct quote. Anyway, so Britain is a country transformed. Britain's lost its empire.
到70年代初，几乎所有前殖民地都已独立。它正在努力为自己寻找新的角色。英国在1973年加入了由保守党领袖泰德·希思领导的欧洲共同体。英国像大多数西方国家一样享受了二十年的经济增长，但有一种感觉，即车轮正在脱落。它正在挣扎。与西德、法国或日本的同行相比，英国企业正在挣扎。而且人们越来越感觉到，英国的重工业，如煤炭、钢铁、造船、汽车制造，时日无多。
By the beginning of the 1970s, almost all the former colonists have become independent. It's struggling to find a new role for itself. Britain has joined the European community under the Tory leader Ted Heath in 1973. Britain has enjoyed two decades of economic growth like most Western countries, but there's a sense that the wheels are coming off. It's struggling. British businesses are struggling compared with their West German, French or Japanese counterparts. And there's a growing sense that Britain's heavy industries, kind of coal, steel, shipbuilding, car making are on borrowed time.
在竞争力方面，英国的市场份额一直在下降。如果你把它与西德（这是一个合理的比较）放在图表上进行对比，那么英国看起来，例如英国的生产力，绝对是糟糕透顶。是的。而且随着时间的推移，相对而言变得越来越糟。所以有这些。最后，还有一种信心危机。这是政治精英阶层中一种疲惫和枯竭的感觉。他们被与英国工会的持续斗争磨得精疲力竭。
Competitively, Britain's market share is dropping all the time. And if you plot it on a graph compared with that, West Germany, say, which is a reasonable comparison, then Britain looks, British productivity, for example, is absolutely terrible. Yeah. And actually gets worse and worse comparatively as the period goes on. So there's that. And then finally, there's a sort of crisis of confidence. So this is a sense among the political elite of weariness and exhaustion. They're ground down by constant battles with Britain's trade unions.
英国拥有这种非常、非常分散的工会制度，许多不同的工会争夺会员。由于它拥有如此多的国有工业，这意味着不是私营公司与工会对抗，而是一次又一次地由政府与工会对抗。它在绑架英国人民。是的，我相信当时使用的专业术语是“工会大亨”。他们总是被称为工会大亨。然后是北爱尔兰。
Britain has this very, very fragmented trade union system, lots of different unions competing for members. And because it has so many nationalised industries, this means that instead of pitting a private company against the trade unions, it's the government against the trade unions time after time. It's holding the British people to ransom. Yeah, I believe the technical term used at the time was trade union barons. They're always called trade union barons. And then there's Northern Ireland.
所以我们应该在某个时候专门做一个关于“动乱”的系列。在这一点上，每年有数百人，250人、300人死亡。所以这是一个真正的长期伤口。正如我们在上一系列中所描述的那样，这一切在1974年那个动荡的年份达到了顶峰。1973年末的石油冲击基本上炸毁了英国经济。好吧，谢天谢地，现在不会发生那种事了。它使通货膨胀飙升，这将是本系列的一个持续主题。
So we should do a series at some point on the troubles specifically. At this point, hundreds of people, 250, 300, are dying every year. So a real running sore. And all of that came to ahead, as we described in our previous series, in the tumultuous year of 1974. The oil shock of late 1973 basically blew up the British economy. Well, thank God, nothing like that's going to happen now. It sent inflation through the roof, and this will be a constant theme of this series.
所以通货膨胀在1975年夏天达到了创纪录的26%。在70年代初担任首相的现代化保守党议员泰德·希思，他失去了对经济的控制。他试图实施一种工资政策，但这引发了煤矿工人的罢工。他在2月举行了选举，试图从人民那里获得新的授权。结果陷入了僵局，形成了一个悬浮议会。他被那个非常“旧货”的人物，前首相、工党的哈罗德·威尔逊所取代。威尔逊收买了工会。
So inflation reached a record 26% in the summer of 1975. The modernising Tory MP, Ted Heath, who was Prime Minister at the beginning of the 70s, he lost control of the economy. He tried to impose a kind of pay policy, but that provoked a strike by the coal mine. He called an election in February to try to get a new mandate from the people. And that ended in a deadlock in a hung parliament, so stalemate. And he was replaced by the very shop-soiled figure, the former Prime Minister, Labour's Harold Wilson. And Wilson paid off the unions.
他带来了工业和平，但通货膨胀变得更糟了。对威尔逊来说，好消息是他10月又举行了一次选举，并以仅仅三个席位的微弱优势获胜。这一切的结果是，特别是在右翼，实际上在国外，到1975年初，人们有一种深刻的感觉，即事情已经变得非常、非常糟糕。英国是“欧洲病夫”，正走向某种末日般的清算。因为你在我们关于1974年的上一系列中提到，有各种各样的人在策划政变，不是吗？是的，将军，他叫什么名字？
He brought industrial peace, but inflation got worse. The upside for Wilson, he calls another election in October, and he eked out a very narrow majority of just three seats. And the result of all this is that, especially on the right, and indeed abroad, there is a profound sense by the beginning of 1975 that something has gone very, very badly wrong. The Britain is the sick man of Europe and it's heading for some sort of apocalyptic reckoning. Because you mentioned in our previous series on 1974 that there are all these kind of people who were plotting coups, weren't there? Yes, General, what's his name?
沃尔特·沃克爵士还是什么名字。是的，他们所有人。还有大卫·斯特林，那个创立了SAS的人，所有这些自愿担任民族团结政府领导人的人。我给你举一个国际认知的例子。1975年初，美国资深记者埃里克·塞瓦雷德在美国哥伦比亚广播公司晚间新闻中发表了一篇报道。塞瓦雷德对观众说，英国的问题不仅仅是她的军事力量正在减弱，经济力量正在衰退。
Sir Walter Walker or whatever's name is. Yeah, all of them. There's David Sterling, the guy who founded the SAS, all these people who are sort of offering themselves. as leaders of a national unity government. I'll give you one example of the international perception. At the beginning of 1975, there was a report on the CBS Evening News in the United States by the veteran American correspondent Eric Severide. And Severide said to the viewers, Britain's problem is not just that her military strength is ebbing and her economic strength weakening.
英国正处于阿连德智利政府的阶段，当时少数派试图将深刻的社会变革强加给多数派。它正在缓慢地漂向一种不可治理的状态，并梦游般地走向一场社会革命。这足以成为一个新闻，哈罗德·威尔逊发表了一份声明，称这完全是不真实的等等。泰晤士报为此发表了一篇长篇社论。它说，你知道，实际上我们没有阿连德的智利那么糟糕，但我们确实很糟糕。我们借了太多的钱。我们在世界舞台上是笑柄。
Britain is at the stage of Allende's Chilean government when a minority tried to force a profound transformation of society upon the majority. It's drifting slowly toward a condition of ungovernability and sleepwalking into a social revolution. And this was enough of a story that Harold Wilson issued a statement saying this was completely untrue and whatnot. And the Times published a long editorial about it. And it said, you know, actually we're not as bad as Ianda's chilly, but we are pretty bad. We're borrowing far too much money. We're porpoise on the world stage.
泰晤士报最后说，这些事实全世界都知道，英国的声望自查理二世作为路易十四的养老金领取者以来，从未如此低落。我的意思是，多米尼克，这又有一种当前情况的回响，不是吗？因为目前英国报纸上有这么多关于我们的军事地位处于17世纪状态的文章。是的，完全是。我的意思是，所有这些美国对英国的辱骂是非常普遍的。这是一种常青的主题。有一种特定的美国记者，最喜欢做的事就是踢前主人一脚。
And the Times ended up by saying these facts are well known to the world where British prestige has not stood so low since child. Charles the second was the pensioner of Louis the 14th. I mean, again, Dominic, there is a kind of echo of present circumstance, isn't there? Because there are so many articles in the British newspapers at the moment about how our military standing is kind of in a 17th century state. Yeah, completely. I mean, this is all the stuff, this American abuse of Britain is very common. It's kind of perennial theme. There's a particular kind of American correspondent that loves nothing better than putting the boot into the former master.
我想这就是原因。总之，这就是玛格丽特·撒切尔崛起的背景。她在50岁那年成为保守党领袖。所以，在我们进入她如何成为保守党领袖之前，我们先看看之前的50年。她出生于，汤姆，你知道，当然，她出生在哪里。她出生在林肯郡的格兰瑟姆。我知道。1925年10月。
I think that's what it is. Anyway, so this is the setting in which Margaret Thatcher emerges. She became Tory leader in the year she turned 50. So before we get into how she became Tory leader, we'll look at the previous 50 years. She was born, Tom, you know, of course, where she was born. She was born in Grantham in Lincolnshire. I do. In October 1925.
对于那些不熟悉格兰瑟姆的人来说，格兰瑟姆是典型的、无聊的英国集镇，不是吗？不。它是。不，它非常无聊。它的前任镇书记员。听听它的镇书记员怎么说。正如镇书记员对雨果·杨所说，这是一个建在狭窄街道上的狭窄城镇，住着狭窄的人。
And Grantham, for people who are not familiar with Grantham, it is the quintessential, boring English market town, isn't it? No. It is. No, it's very boring. It's former town clerk. Listen to its town clerk. As town clerk said to Hugo Young, it was a narrow town built on a narrow street inhabited by narrow people.
80年代初的《太阳报》称它是英国最无聊的城镇。《太阳报》错了。好吧，格兰瑟姆的主街上有一家酒店，最初是一家驿站，爱德华三世和菲利帕王后曾住过那里。我住过那里，你去吃早餐。在那个房间里，就是理查三世签署白金汉公爵死刑令的地方。那并不无聊。大概没什么可看的。
The sun in the early 1980s called it the most boring town in Britain. The sun is wrong. Okay, there's a hotel on the main street of Grantham that was originally a coaching inn where Edward III and Queen Philippa stayed. And I stayed there and you go and have breakfast. And in that room is the place where Richard III signed the death warrant of the Duke of Buckingham. That's not boring. There's nothing to see, presumably.
而且，格兰瑟姆也是苹果掉在艾萨克·牛顿头上的地方。好吧，让我们回到罗伯特·撒切尔。嗯，当然，有那个小杂货店，年轻的玛格丽特·罗伯茨就是在上面长大的，由她的父亲罗伯茨议员经营。你非常巧妙地把我们带回了商店。做得好。所以她的父亲是对她影响最大的人。他叫阿尔弗雷德·罗伯茨。
And also, Grantham is where the apple fell on Isaac Newton. Well, let's get back to Robert Thatcher. Well, of course, there is the little corner shop above which the young Margaret Roberts grew up and which was kept by her father, Alderman Roberts. You've got us very neatly to back to the shop. Very well done. So her father is the key influence on it. He's called Alfred Roberts.
他经营着这家杂货店，他用努力工作、节俭、创业精神等价值观抚养他的两个女儿。阿尔弗雷德·罗伯茨是你绝对教科书式的、20世纪初的、具有公共精神的、值得尊敬的人。我认为他是一个值得尊敬的人。他是一位独立的当地议员。他是财务委员会主席。他是一位议员。他曾短暂担任市长。他是扶轮社主席。他做了所有这些事情。现在，罗伯茨议员认为自己是一个老派的自由主义者。他对政治非常感兴趣。他热爱约翰·斯图尔特·密尔。但他认为现代自由主义者，在阿斯奎斯和劳合·乔治这些流氓和无赖的领导下，
He runs this grocer's shop and he brings his two daughters up with the values of sort of hard work and thrift and entrepreneurship and all this kind of thing. Alfred Roberts is your absolute textbook, early 20th century, public spirited, worthy. I think he's a worthy. He is an independent local councillor. He's the chairman of the finance committee. He's an alderman. He's briefly the mayor. He's the chairman of the Rotary Club. He does all this kind of thing. Now, Alderman Roberts sees himself as an old-fashioned liberal. He's very interested in politics. He loves John Stuart Mill. But he thinks that modern liberals, led by rogues and rascals like Asquith and Lloyd George,
已经把这个党带上了社会主义的道路。所以他现在支持鲍德温和张伯伦的保守党。而玛格丽特·罗伯茨，她对她的父亲绝对是敬畏的。事实上，后来，当她在80年代中期担任首相时，米里亚姆·斯托帕德采访了她，问起她的父亲。玛格丽特·撒切尔回忆起他被投票罢免议员职务、不得不交出长袍的那一天。她在采访中哭了起来。
have taken the party down the road of socialism. And so he now supports the Tory party of Baldwin and Chamberlain. And Margaret Roberts, she is an absolute awe of her father. In fact, later on, when she was Prime Minister in the middle of the 80s, Miriam Stoppard did an interview with her and asked about her father. And Margaret Thatcher recalled the day that he was voted out as Alderman had to give up his robes. And she started crying in the interview.
你知道，这对她来说是一件非常不寻常的事情。事实上，当她在1979年成为首相时，当她在唐宁街10号外那个非常著名的时刻，你知道，当她引用或伪托圣方济各的话时，有人问她对父亲有什么想法，她对摄像机说，我几乎把一切都归功于我的父亲。我真的这么认为。
You know, a very unusual thing for her to do. And actually when she becomes Prime Minister in 1979, when she's outside number 10 in the very famous moment, you know, when she quotes or apocryphly St. Francis of Assisi, she's asked, as she have any thoughts about her father, and she says to the cameras, I owe almost everything to my own father. I really do.
他教导我相信我所相信的一切，而这些正是我在选举中奋斗的价值观。多米尼克，精神分析学家难道不把她从不提母亲这一点看得非常重要吗？他们确实，是的，不仅仅是精神分析学家，基本上每一位传记作者和采访者都这么看。她几乎从不提她的母亲。真的很难弄清楚为什么。她很无聊吗？我想她可能只是有点，她很安静，而且不像，她显然不像她父亲那样对玛格丽特有那么大的智力影响。我的意思是，她既有点害怕她的父亲，我想，但又非常钦佩他。而且我认为，你知道，他显得太高大了。我的意思是，撒切尔一生都被她与男人的关系所定义
brought me up to believe all the things that I do believe, and they're just the values in which I've fought the election. Dominic, don't psychoanalysts make a great deal of the fact that she never mentions her mother. They do, yeah, not just psychoanalysts, but basically every biographer and interviewer. She almost never mentions her mother. Hard really to work out why. Is she very boring? I think she's possibly just a little bit, she's quiet, and not as, she's clearly not as big an intellectual influence on Margaret's as her father is. I mean, she's both slightly terrified of her father, I think, but admires him enormously. And I think, you know, he just looms so large. I mean, Thatcher all her life is defined by her relationships with men
而不是与女人的关系，不是吗？是的，她是。所以这是意料之中的事。他给她的另一件大事是他的卫理公会信仰。所以有几个不同的卫理公会教堂。这会让你高兴，汤姆，相信宗教是国家生活中的巨大影响。格兰瑟姆有几个不同的卫理公会教堂，他们在市中心最受尊敬的卫斯理教堂礼拜。所以他们必须经过靠近商店的其他教堂，才能到达这个受人尊敬的教堂。而卫斯理教堂的氛围仍然相当简朴，你知道，清廉的生活，自我完善，不要玩得太开心。
rather than with women, isn't she? Yeah, she is. So this is part of the course. The other big thing he gives her is his Methodism. So there are several different Methodist chapels. This will please you, Tom, believing that religion is the great influence on national life. There are several different Methodist chapels in Grantham, and they worship at the most respectable, which is the Wesleyan Church in the town centre. So they have to go past other chapels, which are near the shop, to get to this respectable one. And the vibe of the Wesleyan church is still pretty austere, you know, clean living, self-improvement, don't have too much fun.
阿尔弗雷德·罗伯茨非常、非常认真地对待它。他是一位平信徒传教士。他的女儿们周日必须多次去教堂，所以是主日学校，然后是主礼拜，然后可能还有祈祷会之类的。虽然玛格丽特在成年后离开了它，加入了英国国教，这更受人尊敬，但它在她身上留下了巨大的印记，我们实际上会回到这一点，因为我认为这是她身份中非常、非常重要的一部分。所以她是一个聪明的女孩，努力工作，她赢得了牛津大学的席位。后来，当她成为首相时，一些高尚的知识分子批评家无法忍受她上过牛津大学，而且她可能相当聪明。
And Alfred Roberts takes it very, very seriously. he's a lay preacher. His daughters have to go multiple times to church on a Sunday, so Sunday school and then the main service and then maybe a prayer meeting or something. And although Margaret, when she's an adult, leaves it behind and joins the Church of England, which is more respectable still, it leaves a massive imprint on her and we'll actually come back to this because I think it's a huge, huge part of her identity. So she's a clever girl, hardworking, she wins a place at Oxford. Later on, when she became Prime Minister, sort of high-minded intellectual critics could not abide the fact that she had gone to Oxford and that she might be quite clever.
他们会说，哦，她是个傻瓜，你知道，她做过。我曾经参加过一个广播节目。我记得伊迪丝·霍尔愤怒地说，玛格丽特·撒切尔不是一个聪明的女人，在地图上认不出柬埔寨。好吧，伊迪丝·霍尔非常擅长识别她角色的顶级翻译。是吗？她擅长在地图上命名国家吗？这是个问题。我想那一定是她的另一项技能。
And they would say, oh, she's in a fool, you know, she did. I went once was on a radio program. And I remember Edith Hall saying with absolute fury that Margaret Thatcher was not an intelligent woman and couldn't identify Cambodia on a map. Well, Edith Hall is very good at recognising top translations of her role. Is she? Is she good at like naming countries on maps? That's the question. I imagine that must be another of her skills.
我的意思是，大概如果你是首相，地图上会有标签。不，你不需要它。福克兰群岛，我们的。是的，这就是你需要知道的一切。还有什么我不知道的？总之，这显然是胡说八道。好吧，她是化学家，对吧？我的意思是，化学真的很难。
I mean, presumably if your Prime Minister, the maps have labels. No, you don't need it. The Falkland Islands, ours. Yeah, that's all you need to know. What else is I don't know? Anyway, this is obviously rubbish. Well, she's a chemist, right? I mean, chemistry is really difficult.
而且她很擅长。所以她在牛津的导师是多萝西·霍奇金，她是第一位也是唯一一位获得诺贝尔奖的英国女科学家。多萝西·霍奇金在政治上完全不同意她的观点，回忆起她时说，我引用，“一个好学生，人们总是可以指望她写出明智、博学的文章。”你知道，她不是天才，但她仍然非常擅长化学。她在牛津。
And she was good at it. So her tutor at Oxford was Dorothy Hodgkin, who was the first and only British woman scientist ever to win the Nobel Prize. And Dorothy Hodgkin, who didn't agree with her on politics at all, recalled her as, I quote, a good student one could always rely on her producing a sensible, well-read essay. You know, she's not brilliant, but she's still very good at chemistry. She's at Oxford.
我的意思是，我基本上对任何能做化学的人都印象深刻。说得对，完全正确。所以在牛津，她不是一个爱玩的人。她不是一个笑话。加入卫斯理教堂和卫斯理协会。她做了一些传教工作。她加入了保守党协会并成为其主席。但她没有在大学酒吧里闲逛，你知道，喝苹果酒。她是一个工作狂。事实上，她一生中，你知道，为了玩而玩或无所事事的想法对她来说简直是完全
I mean, I'm basically impressed by anyone who can do chemistry. Quite right, exactly. So at Oxford, she's not a fun-loving person. She's not a laugh. joins the Wesleyan Church and the Wesleyan Society. She does some preaching. She joins the conservative association and becomes its president. But she's not hanging out in the college bar, you know, necking ciders. She is a workaholic. And in fact, all through her life, you know, the idea of having fun for its own sake or doing nothing just strikes her as completely
疯狂。当还有更多工作要做时，你为什么要那样做？事实上，即使作为首相，下班后，当她停止工作并和她的助手们闲逛时，她只是谈论社会主义的罪恶。我的意思是，他们对此非常有趣，她在80年代的许多助手。他们说，你知道，她只是会给我们这些大规模的讲座，好像我们还没有同意她一样。但我们就像她最不需要说服的人。不过她确实有看男人的眼光，不是吗？她确实有。所以像塞西尔·帕金森或后来的约翰·摩尔。一个穿细条纹西装穿得很好的男人。她喜欢穿细条纹西装、头发抹油、眼神中或许有一丝闪光的男人
insane. Why would you do that when there's more work to be done? And actually, even as Prime Minister, after work, when she stops work and she's hanging around with her aides and whatnot, she just talks about the evils of socialism. I mean, they're very funny about this, a lot of her aides in the 80s. They say, you know, she would just give us these massive lectures as though we didn't already agree with her. But we were like the last people that she needed to convince. She does have an eye for a cad, though, doesn't she? She totally does. So kind of Cecil Parkinson or John Moore later on. A man who wears a pinstripe suit well. She loves a man in a pinstripe suit with brule-creamed hair who perhaps has a little glint in his
那非常不是她喜欢的。所以她在牛津确实有一个男朋友叫托尼·布雷。她喜欢跳舞。所以当她是首相时，她的一大爱好就是和罗纳德·里根跳舞。而且她喜欢时尚，不是吗？是的，她真的很喜欢时尚。所以查尔斯·摩尔的传记里有信件，她写给姐姐的信说，我真的很想买这些新鞋，这些迷人的新鞋，但我知道我们的父亲不会赞成。所以她和她父亲之间确实有一点紧张。她唯一没有的，我的意思是，她没有的是任何讽刺感。或荒谬感。她生活和职业生涯中一个有趣的方面，
die. That's very much not she likes. So she did have a boyfriend at Oxford called Tony Bray. She loved dancing. So when she was prime minister, one of her great passions was to dance with Ronald Reagan. And she loves fashion, doesn't she? Yeah, she really likes fashion. So there's letters in Charles Moore's biography, letters that she's writing to her sister saying, I'd really like to get these new shoes, these glamorous new shoes, but I know that our father would not approve. So there is a little bit of tension there with her father. The one thing she doesn't, I mean, what she doesn't have, she doesn't have any sense of irony. or the absurd. A fun aspect of her life and career,
她对双关语完全无知。所以她有一次去帕特尼竞选，她看到一个男人拿着一把大扳手，她对媒体团说，天哪，我从来没见过那么大的工具。所以他们都开始笑。而她只是不明白他们为什么笑。然后最好的是，她在1983年去了福克兰群岛，
she's completely oblivious to dublo entres. So she went to campaigning once in Putney, and she saw a man carrying a big wrench, and she said to the press corps, goodness, I've never seen a tool as big as that. So they all start laughing. And she just doesn't understand why they're laughing. And then the best one is she went to the Falklands in 1983,
当胜利已经确保时。那里有一门大的野战炮。他们说，你想坐在这门野战炮上吗？并开几发炮弹，就像，你知道，朝着阿根廷的方向或什么的。她说，她很心动，然后她对他们说，但它会不会把我震下来？再一次，每个人都，你知道，没有干眼。有时有人说她是庸人。她在80年代的许多批评家都这么说。
when victory had been secured. And there was a big sort of field gun. And they said, would you like to sit on this field gun? and fire some rounds, like just, you know, in the very direction of Argentina or whatever. And she said, she was tempted, and then she said to them, but mightn't it jerk me off? And again, everybody's sort of not a dry eye in the house. It's sometimes said of her that she's a Philistine. A lot of her critics said this in the 80s.
作家乔纳森·拉宾说，她把书籍、艺术和思想仅仅视为黑森林蛋糕。太70年代了。我知道，但我认为黑森林蛋糕。是一件好事。我认为那是一个恭维。总之，她喜欢古典音乐。她喜欢肖邦。她喜欢贝多芬。她喜欢巴赫。我们从档案中的信件中知道，在70年代作为反对党领袖。我不认为凯米·巴德诺克在做这个。
The writer Jonathan Rabin said she regarded books, art and ideas as just so much Black Forest Gatto. So 70s. I know, but I regard Black Forest Gato. is a good thing. I think that's a compliment. Anyway, she liked classical music. She liked Chopin. She liked Beethoven. She liked Bach. We know from letters in the archives that in the 70s as leader of the opposition. I don't think Kimmy Bajnock is doing this.
她读了陀思妥耶夫斯基的《群魔》。她有《正午的黑暗》。她有勒卡雷。她读吉卜林、索尔仁尼琴。她有哈罗德·布鲁姆。她不是著名地读了两遍《豺狼的日子》吗？那是真的吗？我的意思是，我从来没听说过。我想她从头读到尾，然后又读了一遍，试图弄清楚情节。哇。你知道，所以我可能是一个工程师，一种，你知道，
She read Dostoevsk's demons. She had Curses, Darkness at noon. She had Le Carrey. She read Kipling, Salt Sinitsyn. She had Harold Bloom. Didn't she famously read The Day of the Jackal twice? Is that right? I mean, I've never heard that. I think she read it all the way through, and then she read it again to try and work out the plot. Wow. You know, so I kind of engineer perhaps, a kind of, you know,
科学家的视角来看看它是如何。是的，看看它是如何运作的。看看它的化学成分。是的。我的意思是，就音乐这个话题，你一定知道她最喜欢的披头士歌曲。钱。那是前男人。Telstar。
scientists' perspective to see how it. Yeah, to see how it worked. To see the chemical composition of it. Yeah. I mean, just on the topic of music, you must know her favorite Beatles song. Money. It's a ex-man. Telstar.
Telstar。当然，那不是披头士乐队的。是的，那太疯狂了。但她可能喜欢它，因为她会说，我喜欢长发之前的流行音乐。是的，她不喜欢那个。那可能是问题所在？事实上，在长发和唱歌之前。
Telstar. Which, of course, was not by the Beatles. Yeah, that's insane. But she probably likes it because she would like, she would say, I'd like popular music before the long hair. Yeah, she didn't like that. That probably the issue? Before the long hair and the singing, in fact.
正确。所以我驳斥了她是一个庸人或者，你知道，她不太聪明的几个批评。然而，绝对真实的是，她没有任何真正的想象力或同理心。几乎她所有的传记作者，所有与她共事过的人，都说这是巨大的弱点。基本上，玛格丽特·撒切尔并不真正理解，当然不是在情感层面上，与她不同是什么感觉，贫穷、不安全是什么感觉，实际上没有野心、被人们说你应该靠自己的努力站起来或者倒霉是什么感觉。或者失业。
Correct. So I've sort of shot down a couple of the criticisms that she's a Philistine or whatever or that, you know, she's not very clever. What is absolutely true, however, is that she doesn't have any real sense of imagination or empathy. Almost all her biographers, everybody who worked with her, said this was the massive weak point. That basically, Margaret Thatcher did not really understand, certainly not on an emotional level, what it was like to be different from her, what it was like to be poor, to be, insecure, what it was like actually not to be ambitious and to be intimidated by people saying you should pull yourself up by your bootstraps or to be unlucky. Or to lose your job.
失业，完全正确。我认为比任何其他事情都更能捕捉到她特点的事情。这是马修·帕里斯回忆录中的一段话。马修·帕里斯，《泰晤士报》专栏作家，在70年代为她工作。有一次他对她说，他们在某个聚会上见面，他说，我要去荒凉群岛。我想奥布里和马图林去了荒凉群岛，不是吗？在《怒海争锋》的故事里。
To lose your job, exactly. The thing that always, I think, captures her better than anything else. It's a passage in Matthew Paris's memoir. Matthew Paris, the Times columnist, worked for her in the 1970s. And there's a point when he says to her, they meet at some party and he says, I'm going off to the desolation islands. I think Aubrey and Maturin go to the desolation islands, don't they? in Master and Commander stories.
他说，我要去荒凉群岛旅行。她对他说，我知道你为什么想去。你想去几千英里外某个遥远而危险的地方，爬到山顶，说，我在这里，在一个荒野而危险的地方，离任何地方都有几英里远，看着月亮和星星。这正是他想去的原因。她说，听我的建议，亲爱的，别费心了。
He says, I'm going to the desolation islands on a trip. And she said to him, I know why you want to go. You want to go thousands of miles to some remote and dangerous place and climb to them atop of a mountain and to say, here I am in a wild and dangerous place, miles from anywhere, look at the moon and the stars. That's exactly why he wants to go. And she said, take my advice, dear, don't bother.
你可以从斯伯丁看到月亮和星星。我认为，这完全捕捉到了。她有一种局限性，一种狭隘。你知道，尽管她有种种优点，但她缺乏想象力。我想，在晚宴上坐在她旁边不会是一个非常有趣的人。可能比特蕾莎·梅更有趣。是的，我的意思是，她读过陀思妥耶夫斯基。你可以和她谈论陀思妥耶夫斯基。
You can see the moon and the stars from Spalding. And that, I think, completely captures. there's a sort of a limit, a narrowness to her. You know, for all her strengths, there's a lack of imagination. She would not be a terribly fun person, I think, to sit next to it at a dinner party. Probably more fun than Theresa May. Yeah, I mean, she's read Dostoevsky. You could talk to her about Dostoevsky.
所以让我们回到故事。她离开牛津，成为一名研究化学家，实际上，有一次是为狮子冰淇淋公司工作。她试图在下议院寻找一个安全的席位。她备受推崇。1950年和1951年在达特福德竞选时的当地代理人说，她是一位令人惊叹的年轻女性，拥有超越她年龄的经验和知识，出色的能力，此外还有非常有吸引力的个性和外表。同意这一点的人之一是一位在达特福德见到她的商人，
So let's get back to the story. She leaves Oxford, becomes a research chemist, actually, for the Lions ice cream company at one point. She tries to find a safe seat in the House of Commons. she's highly thought of. The local agent in Dartford, where she stood in 1950 and 1951, said she was an amazing young woman with experience and knowledge far beyond her years, outstanding inability, and has in addition a most attractive personality and appearance. And one of the people who agrees with this is a businessman who meets her in Dartford,
他叫丹尼斯·撒切尔。他离过婚。他大得多。他大10岁。但他们结婚了，生了一对双胞胎，马克和卡罗尔。她改行当了大律师。她成为1959年芬奇利的保守党候选人。她在50年代的过程中改变了自己
who is called Dennis Thatcher. And he's divorced. He's much older. He's 10 years older. But they get married and they have twins, Mark and Carol. She retrains as a barrister. She becomes the Tory candidate for Finchley in 1959. She transforms herself in the course of the 50s
从那种卫理公会文法学校的女孩变成了更像家乡郡的保守党母亲、妻子和母亲。所以她的孩子在私立学校。她去英国国教教堂。她有了这种新的口音，那种“切玻璃”般的口音，她有这些非常夸张的帽子。事实上，人们把她的帽子与
from the sort of Methodist grammar school girl to a more of a home county's Tory sort of mother, wife and mother. So she's got her kids at private school. She goes to the Church of England. She has this new accent, kind of cut glass accent, and she has these very extravagant hats. In fact, it's her hats that people associate with, though,
这个时期联系在一起，胜过其他任何东西。她的口音偶尔会流露出来，不是吗？所以著名的是，她说尼尔·基诺克是“Fritt”，这是一种格兰瑟姆方言。是的，但那几乎是唯一一次。是的。从来没有任何暗示表明她实际上不是来自英格兰南部，真的。显然，阻碍她的一件事是她作为女性的问题。而且我认为，实际上，在她的首相任期内，人们几乎低估了这对她的政治身份有多重要。她显然不是女权主义者。
this period more than anything else. Her accent does occasionally broke through, doesn't it? So famously, she said of, was it Neil Kinnock that he was Fritt, which was a, a Granthamism. Yeah, but that's virtually the only time. Yeah. There's never a hint that she's actually not from the South of England, really. The one thing, obviously, that's holding her back is the issue of her being a woman. And I think, actually, during her premiership, people almost underrated how important this was to her political identity. She's obviously not a feminist.
她蔑视女权主义，女权主义者大体上恨她。但她作为职业妻子和母亲是非常不寻常的。她总是支持职业女性。所以50年代，她为《青年保守党杂志》撰稿。她说，你知道，如果一个女人有野心，她应该能够充分利用她的才能。那不是女权主义的观点吗？嗯，你可能会说它是。
She disdains feminism, and feminists by and large hated her. But she's very unusual in being a working wife and mother. She always stuck up for working women. So in the 1950s, she wrote in for the Young Conservative Journal. And she said, you know, if a woman has ambition, she should be able to use her talent to the full. Isn't that a feminist perspective? Well, you might say that it was.
是的，我的意思是，她有一次说，蔑视职业女性的男人应该记住，他们的女儿几乎肯定不得不出去工作。你知道，这就是我们正在进入的世界。我不认为那是一个非女权主义的观点。不，当然。我也不认为它是非女权主义的。我认为在很多方面，她是社会和文化变革的化身，这些变革在1950年到1980年间极大地扩展了英国女性的视野。
Yeah, I mean, she said at one point men who disdain working women should remember their daughters would almost certainly have to go out to work. You know, this is the world we are moving into. I don't see that as being an unfeminist perspective. No, of course. I don't see it as unfeminist either. I think in lots of ways she's the embodiment of the social and cultural changes that are massively expanding the horizons of British women between the 1950s and the 1980s.
当然，问题是，她不喜欢任何形式的活动家，真的，她不喜欢进步的“好好先生”。所以她与70年代的女性生活运动不太合拍。她作为女性既是优势也是劣势。首先，这意味着她从所有穿灰色西装的无聊男人中脱颖而出。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的
The thing is, of course, she doesn't like activists of any kind, really, and she doesn't like progressive do-gooders. So she doesn't sit well with the kind of women's lives. live movement of the 1970s. Her being a woman is both a strength and a weakness. First of all it means that she stands out from all the boring men in grey suits. I mean, that is a huge
事情，如果你是一名政治家。每个人都会立即认出你，你与众不同。然而，因为她是女性，这意味着人们总是谈论她的帽子、她的服装，你知道，她作为母亲做得怎么样，所有这些事情，而不是她的
thing for you if you're a politician. Everyone immediately recognises you and you stand apart. Because she's a woman though, it means that people always talk about her hats, her outfits, you know, how she's getting on as a mother, all of this kind of thing, rather than her
政治观点。而且因为她是女性，她的保守党同事对她看得轻得多，并驳回了她的想法。这方面的典型例子是60年代末和70年代的领导人，即泰德·希思。有趣的是，希思和撒切尔在某些方面非常相似。他们都来自谦逊的省份背景。他们都上过文法学校。他们都上过牛津。他们都稍微有点缺乏幽默感、有野心、不耐烦、某种程度上是白手起家。我认为区别在于，希思年纪稍大，他的背景更卑微。
political opinions. And because she's a woman, her Tory colleagues take her much less seriously and dismiss her ideas. And the paradigmatic example of this is the person who is the leader in the late 1960s and 1970s, which is Ted Heath. And the funny thing about this is that Heath and Thatcher are pretty similar in some ways. They're both from modest provincial backgrounds. They both went to grammar school. They both went to Oxford. They're both slightly humorless, ambitious, impatient, kind of self-made. The difference, I think, is that Heath who's a bit older, his background is more humble.
他是肯特郡建筑工人的儿子。他母亲是女仆，不是吗？他母亲是女仆，完全正确。女仆总是以势利眼而闻名。她们非常势利，完全正确。他非常热衷于淡化自己的背景，基本上把自己变成一种贝利奥尔学院教育的、上层阶级的保守党人，因此他有那种疯狂的声音，那种被勒住的声音。
He's the son of a Kentish builder. And his mother was a lady's maid, wasn't he? His mother was a lady's maid, exactly. Ladies' maids are always notorious as snobs. They're very snobbish, exactly. And he is very keen to play down his background and basically turn himself into a kind of bailiol-educated upper-crossed Tory, hence his mad voice that he has, that sort of strangulated voice.
被勒住的，是的。那是总是被使用的形容词，不是吗？他喜欢游艇、古典音乐，这些都是他装出来的上层阶级品味。而且他从来、从来不谈论他的背景。撒切尔并不为她的背景感到尴尬，也许是因为它稍微更受人尊敬一点。她以中产阶级身份为荣。
Strangulated, yeah. That's the adjective that's always used, isn't it? His fun fun for yachting for classical music, these are all kind of upper class tastes that he affects. And he never, ever talks about his background. Thatcher is not embarrassed by her background, perhaps because it was a little bit more respectable. She glories in the middle class identity.
她讨厌她所说的“建制派”，那些鄙视她的粗呢乡村绅士。所以她比希思更明显地是一个资产阶级捍卫者。现在希思从1949年就认识她了。他不喜欢女人，他也不太喜欢她。但当他成为保守党领袖时，有人告诉他，你需要一个“法定女性”。那是当时的表达。
She hates the sort of what she calls the establishment, the tweedy country gents who despise her. And so she is much more obviously a sort of bourgeois champion than Heath is. Now Heath has known her since 1949. He doesn't like women and he doesn't really like her. But he is told when he becomes Tory leader, you need a statutory woman. That was the expression.
他问他的朋友，我该选谁？他们说，玛格丽特·撒切尔怎么样？她是这里最聪明的。他说，好吧，公平合理。他的朋友威利·怀特劳对他说，一旦她到了那里，我们就永远无法摆脱她了。他当然是对的。现在这告诉了你关于她通常被看待的方式的一些事情。
And he asked his friends, who shall I pick? And they said, what about Margaret Thatcher? She's the brightest. He said, okay, fair enough. And Willie Whitelaw, his friend, said to him, once she's there, we will never get rid of her. And he was, of course, quite right. Now that tells you something about the way in which she's viewed generally.
他问他的朋友们，我该选谁？他们说，玛格丽特·撒切尔怎么样？她是最聪明的。他说，好吧，有道理。他的朋友威利·怀特劳对他说，一旦她上台，我们就再也无法摆脱她了。当然，他说得完全正确。这说明了人们普遍是如何看待她的。
So part of this is her class. So White Law said she was governessy. Francis Pym another Heathite. She was a corporal, not a cavalry officer. Christopher Soames, what was he, Churchill's grandson or something, called her a jumped-up housemaid. This was a very, very common in the sort of the Heath inner circle. People sneering at her because of her class.
所以这部分原因在于她的阶级。怀特劳说她有家庭教师的派头。弗朗西斯·皮姆是另一位希思派。她是个下士，而不是骑兵军官。克里斯托弗·索姆斯——他是丘吉尔的孙子还是什么的——称她为“暴发户女佣”。这在希思的核心圈子里非常、非常普遍。人们因为她的阶级而对她冷嘲热讽。
Her politics part of this, being right-wing at this point, the late 60s, early 70s, is seen as a bit, It's a bit gauche, a bit declassé. Because the vibe in the Tory party at this point is paternalist, is it? Exactly. It's more paternalist. It's more, you know, this is the modern world, having multiple phones in your office with which you can ring trade union leaders
她的政治立场也是原因之一，在60年代末、70年代初，这种右翼立场被认为有点……有点粗俗，有点掉价。因为当时保守党的氛围是家长式的，对吧？没错。更偏向家长式。更像是，你知道，这是现代世界，你的办公室里有几部电话，你可以给工会领袖打电话，
and agree a mutually beneficial deal. Tipping your gamekeeper, making sure he's all right. Yes. At Christmas. Exactly. Exactly. And not sort of glorying in your achievements or your wealth or the fact that you have, you know, hold yourself up by your bootstraps, which is a bit common. Buying your own furniture.
然后达成互惠互利的协议。给你的猎场看守人小费，确保他过得不错。是的。在圣诞节的时候。没错。没错。而不是那种炫耀你的成就、你的财富，或者你靠白手起家获得成功的事实，这被认为有点俗气。自己买家具。
Yes, it's buying your own furniture, exactly. And it's also her style. A lot of men just don't like her style, which is quite abrasive and sharp. So Woodrow Wyatt, in the Sunday Mirror in 1969, he ended up being a big fan of her, but this stage he was not. Anti-feminists may feel she is the sort of thing that happens if you allow women to go into politics. Her air of bossiness, her aptitude for interfering, can be very tiresome and irritating to easygoing men who do not always want to be kept up to scratch, particularly by a female. That, I mean, that last bit absolutely captures the sort of golf club vibe of the late 60s and 70s, doesn't it? Anyway, Heath becomes Prime Minister in 1970.
是的，就是自己买家具，没错。还有她的风格。很多男人就是不喜欢她的风格，相当尖刻犀利。所以伍德罗·怀亚特在1969年的《星期日镜报》上，他最终成了她的忠实粉丝，但在那个阶段他不是。反女权主义者可能会觉得，这就是允许女性进入政坛后会发生的事情。她那种爱发号施令的样子，她那种好管闲事的倾向，对于那些并不总是想被督促、特别是被女性督促的随和男性来说，可能会非常令人厌烦和恼火。我的意思是，最后那一点绝对捕捉到了60年代末和70年代高尔夫球俱乐部的氛围，不是吗？总之，希思在1970年当选首相。
She becomes his education secretary. Education was traditionally seen as, that's what you get the little ladies to do. Yeah. You know, education or health. The kind, caring jobs. The civil servants to the Department of Education by and large hated her. they were Oxford-educated public school men themselves. One of them said she was like a very well-spoken nanny,
她成为了他的教育大臣。教育在传统上被视为“那是让小女士们去做的事”。是的。你知道，教育或卫生。那种友善、关怀的工作。教育部的大部分公务员都讨厌她。他们自己都是牛津毕业的公立学校男学生。其中一个人说她就像一个说话非常得体的保姆，
which tells you where he was coming from. She had a totally unoriginal mind. She was really quite narrow. Her permanent secretary was called Sir, the excellent name was Sir William Pyle. Sir William Pyle. He said, she was narrow-minded, emotional, impossible to argue with.
这说明了他的立场。她的思想完全没有原创性。她真的很狭隘。她的常务次官叫威廉·派尔爵士，名字很棒。威廉·派尔爵士。他说，她心胸狭隘、情绪化，根本无法与之争论。
a world apart, unaware of how most of the population lived. The knowledge of history was nil. So these are obviously former public schoolboys. They don't want some Midlands, you know, grammar school girl who did chemistry to come and tell them what to do. Horrible. And this was widespread even in the cabinet. So whenever she was speaking in the cabinet, Heath would, people would say Heath would drum impatiently on his blotter. Because Heath is notoriously rude. That's something that listeners have to keep and bear in mind. He's insanely rude. He is the rudest man ever. to have been Prime Minister. But actually the rudeness is quite common. So Reginald Maudling, who was his home secretary, who was like a man who, what did he? He used to drink a pint of
与世隔绝，不知道大多数人是怎么生活的。历史知识为零。所以这些人显然都是前公立学校的学生。他们不想让一个来自米德兰兹的、你知道的、学化学的文法学校女孩来告诉他们该怎么做。太可怕了。这种情况甚至在内阁中也很普遍。所以每当她在内阁发言时，希思就会——人们会说希思会不耐烦地敲打他的吸墨纸。因为希思以粗鲁著称。这是听众必须记住的一点。他极其粗鲁。他是担任过首相的人里最粗鲁的一个。但实际上这种粗鲁相当普遍。所以雷金纳德·莫德林，他的内政大臣，那个……他做了什么？他过去早餐时会喝一品脱
Dubonnet and gin for breakfast. It's very, very 70s Britain. He called it and I quote, that bloody woman who never listens, that bitch. And that's basically, that's the conversational tenor of Ted Heath's Tory party. And just to reiterate, she is the only woman in the cabinet. Yes, exactly. So you can imagine, basically, the cabinet break. takes up, they all go off to a gentleman's club and drink Jubonet and gin and get absolutely wrecked and talk about the Second World War and, you know, being kind to the trade unions. And she's on her own. She has to go back home to the twins and whatnot, knowing that they're all talking about
杜本内和金酒。这非常、非常具有70年代英国的特色。他称她为——我引用一下——“那个从不听人说话的该死的女人，那个婊子”。这基本上就是泰德·希思保守党的谈话基调。再说一遍，她是内阁中唯一的女性。是的，没错。所以你可以想象，基本上，内阁休息时，他们都去绅士俱乐部喝杜本内和金酒，喝得烂醉如泥，谈论第二次世界大战，还有，你知道，对工会要友善。而她孤身一人。她必须回家照顾双胞胎什么的，知道他们都在谈论
her and saying, that bloody woman, she never listens. But I suppose she can console herself by slatching milk out from the hands of little children. So this is her one brush of fame as Education Secretary. She scrapped free school milk for children between the ages of seven and eleven. and everyone said she was the milk snatcher. And this is a totally mad and confected issue because the Wilson government, the Labor government of the 60s,
她，说“那个该死的女人，她从不听人说话”。但我猜她可以安慰自己，从小孩手中夺走牛奶。所以这是她作为教育大臣唯一一次出名。她取消了7到11岁儿童的免费学校牛奶。每个人都叫她“牛奶掠夺者”。这是一个完全疯狂且捏造的问题，因为威尔逊政府，60年代的工党政府，
had already scrapped free school milk for 11 to 18-year-olds. This was basically the next step. Most kids hated this free school milk anyway, and it was a hangover from the 40s meant to deal with the depression. I mean, the idea that they were giving out all this free school milk,
已经取消了11到18岁学生的免费学校牛奶。这基本上是下一步。大多数孩子本来就讨厌这种免费学校牛奶，而且这是40年代为了应对萧条而留下的产物。我的意思是，他们发放所有这些免费学校牛奶的想法，
and I think it's bonkers anyway. Thatcher's Education Secretary, here's the thing that made surprise listeners. She is much more mainstream And indeed, in some ways, much more progressive than you might expect. She closed more grammar schools and turned them into comprehensive schools. Later, you know, a great kind of Tory issue, how terrible this was. So grammar schools, just to explain for people, are selective, selected on ability,
而且我觉得这本来就很疯狂。撒切尔作为教育大臣，这里有一件事会让听众感到惊讶。她比你预期的要主流得多，而且在某些方面，要进步得多。她关闭了更多的文法学校，并将它们改成了综合学校。后来，你知道，这是一个重大的保守党议题，这有多么糟糕。所以文法学校，给人们解释一下，是选拔性的，根据能力选拔，
but inevitably because ability is honed by money. Yeah. The accusation is that it's a kind of a scam for middle class parents with sharp elbows. Exactly. And so in the 60s and 70s, a lot of these selective schools were turned into comprehensive schools in which everybody went. And this was a great shock to the sort of Tory press and whatnot. She persisted with this program and closed more grammar schools than any other minister in British history. And she didn't bring them back, did she, when she became prime minister, really?
但不可避免地，因为能力是由金钱磨练出来的。是的。指责称这是一种为那些手肘尖锐（善于钻营）的中产阶级父母准备的骗局。没错。所以在60年代和70年代，许多这类选拔性学校被改成了人人都能上的综合学校。这对保守党媒体之类的人来说是一个巨大的冲击。她坚持了这个计划，关闭的文法学校比英国历史上任何其他大臣都多。而且当她成为首相后，她并没有真正把它们恢复，对吧？
I mean, the grammar schools are still an issue today, isn't it? Yeah, if you want to turn something out for the Daily Mail, bringing back grammar school, Oh, really? Yes. I don't think I've ever written a column about bringing back grammar schools. But it was always in the locker, waiting. Anyway, I think this is an example of something that people get massively wrong about Thatcher. They see her as this red-blooded ideologue, you know, fighting tooth and claw for what she believes to be right.
我的意思是，文法学校今天仍然是一个议题，不是吗？是的，如果你想为《每日邮报》炮制点什么，恢复文法学校，哦，真的吗？是的。我想我从来没写过关于恢复文法学校的专栏。但它总是在储物柜里，等待着。总之，我认为这是人们对撒切尔产生巨大误解的一个例子。他们把她看作是一个热血的意识形态家，你知道，为了她认为正确的事情而拼命奋斗。
Never giving up, never giving ground. This is total rubbish. She is a pragmatic career politician. She sits in Ted Heath's cabinet while he's throwing money around. pumping money into the economy, doing deals with the unions, all of this, going into Europe, and she never says a word against it, not a squeak of protest. She just basically goes along with it. Is that because she feels that she's bound by collective responsibility of the cabinet?
从不放弃，从不退让。这完全是胡说八道。她是一个务实的职业政客。当希思在内阁里挥金如土时，她坐在他的内阁里。向经济注入资金，与工会达成交易，所有这些，加入欧洲，她从来没有说过一句反对的话，连一声抗议都没有。她基本上只是随波逐流。这是因为她觉得她受到内阁集体责任制的约束吗？
Yeah, partly, partly, but also she's a politician. It's her job in a way to, you know, she wants to thrive in the party. She wants to get on. She wants to, lots of politicians. do this, you accommodate yourself a little bit to the mood of the moment. I mean, when she's having a drink in private, she probably says, I wonder if we're, you know, going a little bit too far down the corporatist road. But she's not one to rock the boat, basically.
是的，部分原因，部分原因，但她也是一个政客。在某种程度上，她的工作是，你知道，她想在党内茁壮成长。她想进步。她想，很多政客都这样做，你稍微适应一下当时的氛围。我的意思是，当她在私下喝酒时，她可能会说，我想知道我们是否，你知道，在法团主义的道路上走得太远了。但她基本上不是那种会破坏现状的人。
She's actually amazingly enough, given how she later runs the government. She's a team player at this stage. And when Heath loses in February 74, so he loses that first election of the year, he promotes her. He gives her a really big job, Environment Secretary, which covers planning and housing and things like that. The Torr is used her in the second election of the year in October more than any other minister except Heath. And she has a very unfatharite policy. She will cap your mortgage interest rate a 9.5% irrespective of wider interest rates or the state of the economy. And otherwise they will basically rig the interest rates, which is not something you would expect from a free market here at all.
实际上，令人惊讶的是，考虑到她后来管理政府的方式。在这个阶段，她是一个团队合作者。当希思在74年2月输掉选举时，也就是他输掉那年第一次选举时，他提拔了她。他给了她一份非常重要的工作，环境大臣，涵盖规划、住房之类的事情。保守党在10月那年的第二次选举中对她的使用比除希思以外的任何大臣都多。她有一项非常“非撒切尔”的政策。她将你的抵押贷款利率上限设定为9.5%，而不考虑更广泛的利率或经济状况。否则他们基本上会操纵利率，这根本不是你从一个自由市场主义者那里所期望的。
Anyway, the Tories lose that election in October And the verdict is generally that she's done very well And she's been their big star And actually some papers say You know, if Ted Heath were ever to go She could be a dark horse candidate I mean she's never realistically going to win But she could have a hat in the ring and do quite well
总之，保守党在10月输掉了那场选举，普遍的评价是她做得非常好，她是他们的大明星。实际上一些报纸说，你知道，如果泰德·希思真的要走，她可能是一个黑马候选人。我的意思是，她不可能真正获胜，但她可以参与竞争，表现得相当不错。
Who knows? And I quote Sunday Times She's a real contender Despite the apparent handicap that she is a woman And at this point it is seen as that very unlikely that a woman could lead. She has said so herself. So there's a children's program she went on in 1973.
谁知道呢？我引用《星期日泰晤士报》的话：“她是一个真正的竞争者，尽管她身为女性是一个明显的劣势。”在这一点上，女性能够领导被认为是非常不可能的。她自己也这么说过。所以有一个儿童节目，她在1973年参加过。
Val meets the VIPs, that's it. And they meet celebrities, and she's the celebrity. And a child says, would you like to be prime minister? And she says, I would not wish to be prime minister, dear. I have not enough experience for that job. And this is only two years before she becomes party leader. And before that, she told the local newspaper in Finchley, where she's an MP, There will never be a woman, Prime Minister in my lifetime.
《瓦尔会见贵宾》，就是这个。他们会见名人，而她是那个名人。一个孩子问，你想成为首相吗？她说，我不想成为首相，亲爱的。我没有足够的经验来胜任那份工作。而这距离她成为党魁只有两年时间。在此之前，她告诉她在芬奇利的当地报纸，她是那里的议员，“在我有生之年，永远不会有女首相。”
The male population is too prejudiced. Ken, quite a feminist perspective. Well, yeah, I guess so. And I think she absolutely believes that. Everyone knows her dream is to be Chancellor. She basically is Rachel Reeves. Only slightly funnier. Is she funnier?
“男性群体太有偏见了。”肯，相当女权主义的观点。嗯，是的，我想是这样。而且我认为她绝对相信这一点。每个人都知道她的梦想是成为财政大臣。她基本上就是瑞秋·里夫斯。只是稍微有趣一点。她更有趣吗？
I mean, she's... I mean, you... No one can be less funny than Rachel Reeves. I mean, imagine you went to a stand-up night. And it was like, Rachel Reeves and Margaret Thatter on the bill, your heart would sink so... Oh, my God. Anyway, so what changes?
我的意思是，她……我的意思是，你……没有人能比瑞秋·里夫斯更无趣了。我的意思是，想象一下你去参加一个单口喜剧之夜。如果瑞秋·里夫斯和玛格丽特·撒切尔在节目单上，你的心会沉下去，所以……哦，天哪。总之，那么是什么改变了呢？
So in October 74, Heath has lost two elections in nine months, and the Tories are down to 36%. Everybody thinks that Heath is going to resign. He kind of has to resign now. He's lost loads of elections. But Heath is the world's most stubborn man, and he has no intention of resigning. He thinks, well, I was right. The British people were wrong. I shouldn't be given another chance in which they can redeem themselves.
所以在74年10月，希思在九个月内输掉了两次选举，保守党的支持率降到了36%。每个人都认为希思会辞职。他现在有点必须辞职了。他输掉了大量的选举。但希思是世界上最固执的人，他根本没有辞职的打算。他想，好吧，我是对的。英国人民错了。我不应该再得到一个让他们可以自我救赎的机会吗？
And Heath, weirdly, given his rudeness, he inspires tremendous loyalty from his lieutenant. So the obvious person to succeed him would be his lieutenant Willie White Law, who we'll talk about in the second half. But none of them have the sort of have the ruthlessness to challenge him. So Heath does make one concession. He says, I'll put myself up for re-election in January. And a challenger will only need two nominations, so any Tory MP could plausibly challenge him.
而且希思，奇怪的是，考虑到他的粗鲁，他激发了下属极大的忠诚。所以接替他的显而易见的人选应该是他的副手威利·怀特劳，我们将在下半场讨论他。但他们中没有人有那种挑战他的无情。所以希思确实做了一个让步。他说，我会在一月份让自己参加连任选举。而挑战者只需要两个提名，所以任何保守党议员都可以合理地挑战他。
Now, there is one Tory MP who everyone thinks will challenge him, and this is his former secretary at the Department of Health and Social Security, who is Sir Keith Joseph. Keith Joseph had been a sort of conventional minister, but then in 74 he had a massive conversion experience. He said, I was wrong about everything. We've been wrong as a party. We haven't been properly conservative.
现在，有一位保守党议员，每个人都认为他会挑战他，这就是他前卫生和社会保障部的大臣，基思·约瑟夫爵士。基思·约瑟夫曾是一位传统的部长，但在74年，他经历了一次巨大的转变。他说，我在所有事情上都错了。我们作为一个政党错了。我们没有真正地保守。
We should embrace free market liberalism, and I will stand against Ted Heath. But then Keith Joseph, a little bit like Gino Powell, goes to Birmingham, which you should never do as a politician, and gives a speech that destroys himself. He says,
我们应该拥抱自由市场自由主义，我将站出来反对泰德·希思。但随后基思·约瑟夫，有点像吉诺·鲍威尔，去了伯明翰——作为政客你永远不该去那里——并发表了一场毁掉他自己的演讲。他说，
a human stock is threatened by working-class mothers who are unfit to have children. So they are giving birth to the delinquents of the future. And we should give these classes of people loads of birth control so that they will stop having children. Sterilize them. Is this the implication? Well, it's not a good, it's not a good look, basically. This destroys him. Private Eye, the satirical magazine, referred to him henceforth as Sashith.
“人类的种群受到那些不适合生育孩子的工人阶级母亲的威胁。所以她们正在生下未来的罪犯。我们应该给这些阶层的人大量的避孕措施，这样她们就会停止生育。”给他们绝育。这是暗示吗？嗯，这看起来不太好，基本上。这毁了他。《私家侦探》，那本讽刺杂志，从此称他为“基思爵士”（Sashith）。
which I think is an excellent name. Anyway, on the 21st of November, Sir Sheath went to see his campaign manager and said, I've changed my mind. Obviously, I've disgraced myself. I'm not going to stand after all. And his campaign manager said, Keith, if you're not going to stand,
我觉得这是一个绝妙的名字。总之，在11月21日，“基思爵士”去见了竞选经理，说：“我改变主意了。显然，我丢尽了脸。我毕竟不会参选了。”他的竞选经理说：“基思，如果你不参选，
I will, because somebody who represents our viewpoint has to stand. And this, of course, is Margaret Thatcher. And four days later, she goes to see Ted Heath in the House of Commons, and she says to him, Ted, I'm going to stand against you in the leadership election. And Heath, being Heath, he doesn't even bother to get out of his chair. He just shrugs and he says, you'll lose. Huge drama and we will be finding out after the break.
我会参选，因为必须有人代表我们的观点站出来。”而这，当然就是玛格丽特·撒切尔。四天后，她去下议院见了泰德·希思，她对他说：“泰德，我将在党魁选举中挑战你。”而希思，毕竟是希思，他甚至懒得从椅子上站起来。他只是耸耸肩说：“你会输的。”巨大的戏剧性，我们将在休息后揭晓。
You know, is he right? Or does Mrs. Satcher emerge as leader of the Conservative Party and ultimately prime minister? Any one way to find out? Join us after the break. This episode is brought to you by Tell us Online Security. Oh, tag season is the worst. You mean hack season? Sorry, what?
你知道，他是对的吗？还是撒切尔夫人会成为保守党领袖并最终成为首相？只有一种方法可以知道。休息后加入我们。本集由TELUS在线安全赞助。哦，报税季是最糟糕的。你是说黑客季？抱歉，什么？
Yeah, cybercriminals love tax forms. But I've got TELUS online security. It helps protect against identity theft and financial fraud so I can stress less during tax season or any season. Plan started just $12 a month. Learn more at tellus.com slash online security. No one can prevent all cybercrime or identity theft. Conditions apply.
是的，网络犯罪分子喜欢税表。但我有TELUS在线安全。它有助于防止身份盗窃和金融欺诈，所以我可以在报税季或任何季节减少压力。计划每月仅需12美元。在tellus.com/online-security了解更多。没有人能预防所有的网络犯罪或身份盗窃。条件适用。
Hello, everyone. And welcome back to The Rest is History. the excitement is wild because Margaret Thatcher, despite being a woman and despite not having gone to an expensive public school, has announced her intention to stand for leadership of the world's oldest political party. And clearly everyone thinks this is mad, including her own husband, Dennis, who must be out of your mind, woman. You haven't got a hope. Yes. Yeah, that's the encouragement you want. Thank you, darling.
大家好。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。兴奋之情溢于言表，因为玛格丽特·撒切尔，尽管身为女性，尽管没有上过昂贵的公立学校，已经宣布她打算竞选世界上最古老政党的领导权。显然每个人都认为这很疯狂，包括她自己的丈夫丹尼斯，他一定在想“你疯了吗，女人。你一点希望都没有。”是的。是的，这就是你想要的鼓励。谢谢你，亲爱的。
And Dominic the press, are they rallying behind her or do they also think this is mad? They think it's mad as well, actually. So I mentioned Woodrow Wyatt at the Sunday Mirror. He said the tourists will never elect a limited, bossy, self-righteous and self-complaint woman. Because you're right, he does become a massive fan of hers and a kind of courtier. So it reflects well on Mrs. Satcher that she doesn't bear a grudge. Yeah, although she did hold grudges, actually, but clearly not towards, basically, if people bend the knee, she's like Trumpian in that way. If you bend the knee, she's delighted.
还有多米尼克，媒体，他们是在支持她，还是也认为这很疯狂？实际上，他们也认为这很疯狂。所以我提到了《星期日镜报》的伍德罗·怀亚特。他说保守党永远不会选举一个“有限的、爱发号施令的、自以为是的、自满的女人”。因为你是对的，他确实成了她的忠实粉丝和某种朝臣。所以这反映出撒切尔夫人不记仇是件好事。是的，尽管她确实记仇，实际上，但显然不是针对……基本上，如果人们屈膝，她在那方面就像特朗普一样。如果你屈膝，她会很高兴。
So even the right-wing press, the Daily Express, Derek Marks, she is totally out of touch with anybody but carefully corseted middle-class, middle-aged ladies. Enoch Powell. So Enoch Powell, who at this point has basically left the Conservative Party, he is seen as a bit of a forerunner of thatterism, but he said, they wouldn't put up with those hats and that accent, which is coming from him. Yeah.
所以即使是右翼媒体，《每日快报》的德里克·马克斯说，她与除了那些精心束腰的中产阶级、中年女士之外的任何人完全脱节。伊诺克·鲍威尔。所以伊诺克·鲍威尔，此时基本上已经离开了保守党，他被视为撒切尔主义的某种先驱，但他却说：“他们不会忍受那些帽子和那种口音”，这可是出自他之口。是的。
Well, he didn't wear a hat, did he? No, he didn't, but he did have an entertaining accent. But she has a few things going for her. Number one, she has a very, very smart campaign manager. Oh, yeah, Erie Neve. So this is a tremendous character. So Erie Neve is an old Etonian who was captured by the Germans outside Calais in 1940s. The Germans advanced through France, and he was imprisoned at Colitz Castle.
嗯，他没戴帽子，对吧？不，他没有，但他确实有一种有趣的口音。但她有几点优势。第一，她有一位非常、非常聪明的竞选经理。哦，是的，艾里·尼夫。所以这是一个了不起的人物。艾里·尼夫是一位老伊顿生，1940年在加来外被德国人俘虏。德国人推进法国，他被关押在科尔迪茨城堡。
He escaped brilliantly during a theatrical production, put on by the prisoners of war at Calditz Castle. They tunneled underneath the stage, I think, and he and another bloke, a Dutchman had, when they were making costumes of this play, some of the costumes they'd secretly made were German guards' uniforms. They tunneled under the stage. They escaped out of the stage, went back into the sort of castle grounds. They put on these uniforms, homemade.
他在科尔迪茨城堡战俘们举办的一场戏剧演出中精彩地逃脱了。我想他们挖了舞台下面的隧道，他和另一个家伙，一个荷兰人，当他们制作这出戏的服装时，他们秘密制作了一些德国卫兵的制服。他们挖了舞台下面的隧道。他们从舞台下逃了出来，回到了城堡的庭院里。他们穿上了这些自制的制服。
Then they walked through the lodge of the castle, kind of saluting the guards, kept walking, walked all the way to a row. railway station, got various trains, and basically ended up walking across the Swiss border. It's an incredible, incredible story. You know, he was a massive, massive war hero. Because he spoke German, he was the person at the New Yorkerberg trials who read the indictments to the Nazi war criminals. So that's a nice twist.
然后他们穿过城堡的门房，一边向卫兵敬礼，一边继续走，一直走到火车站，换乘了各种火车，基本上最终走过了瑞士边境。这是一个令人难以置信、难以置信的故事。你知道，他是一位伟大的、伟大的战争英雄。因为他会说德语，他是纽伦堡审判中向纳粹战犯宣读起诉书的人。所以这是一个不错的转折。
So then he became Tory MP, and everyone sort of said, well, an amazing bloat this is, escape from cold hits. And then in 1959, he had a heart attack. Heath was at that point the chief whip of the Tory party and when Aeryneve came back to work after his heart attack Heath said to him, you'd better get out of politics, you're finished. I mean, he literally said, you're finished. So rude.
所以后来他成了保守党议员，每个人都说，哇，这家伙太了不起了，从科尔迪茨逃出来的。然后在1959年，他心脏病发作了。希思当时是保守党的首席党鞭，当艾里·尼夫心脏病发作后回来工作时，希思对他说：“你最好退出政坛，你完了。”我的意思是，他真的说了，“你完了。”太粗鲁了。
Incredibly rude, and Erie Neve was very offended by this. He never forgave Heath. And he basically said to himself, one day, I will get my revenge on that absolute shit of a man, which he does. And he does, yeah. Because he takes over Margaret Thatcher's campaign. He says, look, I'll run your campaign for you.
极其粗鲁，艾里·尼夫对此感到非常冒犯。他从未原谅希思。他基本上对自己说，总有一天，我会向那个绝对是混蛋的男人复仇，他也确实做到了。他做到了，是的。因为他接管了玛格丽特·撒切尔的竞选活动。他说，看，我来为你管理竞选。
The way he does it, he organizes little groups of Tory MPs to have tea with her. Now, Heath would never do this because Heath's so rude and so sort of haughty. But she has tea with these people and, you know, nods and smiles at them and whatnot. And the other thing that Naireney always does that people say is a masterstroke, as though it had never occurred to anyone to do this before. I mean, I don't think it's that, but obviously it is considered a great masterstroke. Whenever people ask him how she's doing, he says, oh, she's doing terribly. She'll never win.
他组织的方式是让一小群保守党议员和她喝茶。现在，希思永远不会这样做，因为希思太粗鲁，太傲慢了。但她和这些人喝茶，你知道，对他们点头微笑之类的。而艾里·尼夫做的另一件事，人们说这是神来之笔，好像以前从来没有人想到过这样做。我的意思是，我不认为这是那样，但显然它被认为是一个伟大的神来之笔。每当人们问他她表现如何时，他说，哦，她表现得太糟糕了。她永远不会赢。
But if you could lend her your vote, that would be very helpful, especially if you would like a really big heavyweight like Willie White Law on the second ballot. Why don't you lend the Philly? Yeah, vote for the Philly. Give the Philly your vote. Go on. She's doing very badly. Margaret would love your vote. And actually, loads of people say, oh, go on then.
但如果你能把你的选票借给她，那将非常有帮助，特别是如果你想在第二轮投票中支持像威利·怀特劳这样真正的重量级人物的话。为什么不借给“小母马”呢？是的，投给“小母马”。把你的票投给“小母马”。去吧。她表现得很差。玛格丽特会很高兴得到你的选票。实际上，很多人说，哦，好吧，那就这样吧。
Yeah, fair enough. So that's part of it. But she's also, I think, profiting from something deeper, which is a more profound shift on the right of British politics. So people like Sir Keith Joseph and indeed Margaret Thatcher, and indeed Enn O'Neill, speak for a lot of Tory MPs and Tory activists and Tory voters and also intellectuals and people sort of right-wing adjacent, who have been very disappointed with Ted Heath's government. These are familiar accusations to us today. They say he's been too weak, he's been too soft, he's been too moderate, he's part of a socialist consensus,
是的，有道理。所以这是其中的一部分。但我认为她也受益于更深层的东西，这是英国政治右翼更深刻的转变。所以像基思·约瑟夫爵士，当然还有玛格丽特·撒切尔，当然还有伊诺克·鲍威尔，代表了许多保守党议员、保守党活动家、保守党选民，以及知识分子和那些右翼边缘的人，他们对泰德·希思的政府感到非常失望。这些指责对我们今天来说很熟悉。他们说他太软弱，太温和，他是社会主义共识的一部分，
he's sucked up to Europe, he's sucked up to the trade unions, he's spent too much money, he hasn't been a real conservative. And you can get away with this sort of thing if you win. But Heath has lost two elections in nine months. Because presumably that brands his kind of conservatism as a conservatism for losers. People don't want it. Yeah, completely. If you're not red-blooded and then you don't win, what's the point?
他向欧洲卑躬屈膝，向工会卑躬屈膝，他花了太多的钱，他不是一个真正的保守派。如果你赢了，你可以逃脱这种事情。但希思在九个月内输掉了两次选举。因为大概这给他的那种保守主义打上了“失败者保守主义”的标签。人们不想要它。是的，完全正确。如果你不是热血的，而且你没有赢，那有什么意义？
You might as well just fight and lose for what you believe in. That's what they say. Do you think Mrs. That's image as a nanny who, of course, gives medicine? Yes. Do you think that helps? Totally. I completely, I think it's a very astute point.
你还不如为了你所信仰的东西去战斗并失败。这就是他们说的。你认为撒切尔夫人作为“保姆”的形象——当然，她会提供药物——有帮助吗？是的。我完全认为这是一个非常敏锐的观点。
I think this is one of the roles that she plays. There are several good biographies of Margaret Thatcher. The most famous ones are the Charles More ones. But the one before that was John Campbell. And he had a passage there where he talked about the different roles that she would play. You know, Nurse Thatcher, Nanny Thatcher, the housewife, all these different things. And Nanny Thatcher is one of the most. common and the most appealing. I think there's a particular kind of man, frankly, who quite
我认为这是她扮演的角色之一。关于玛格丽特·撒切尔有几本很好的传记。最著名的是查尔斯·摩尔写的那些。但在那之前是约翰·坎贝尔。他有一段话谈到了她会扮演的不同角色。你知道，护士撒切尔、保姆撒切尔、家庭主妇，所有这些不同的东西。而“保姆撒切尔”是最常见、最吸引人的角色之一。我认为坦率地说，有一种特定类型的男人，相当
likes it. But also, I think it's when the country's not doing well to basically say, I will sort it out, I will give you the medicine you need. That's quite a good card to play, I think. Well, people say that about British politics now, that someone needs to stand up and say, it's all a terrible mess. This is what we've got to do, harsh medicine. Of course, exactly. And there's a kind of massacist strain that people quite like that. Exactly. So, and there's definitely an appetite on the right for more kind of red meat. So, it's a lovely letter, I think, to the Times by Sir Alec Douglas Hume, the former Prime Minister's brother, William. And he said, it's time for a Tory who's not ashamed, who will let you buy your Rolls, Royce and cigars, if that's what you want, and send your boys to Eaton. And if any man attempts to say you, nay, salute him with two fingers in the shape of an inverted V sign.
喜欢它。而且，我认为当国家表现不佳时，基本上说“我会解决它，我会给你需要的药物”，这是一个很好的牌，我想。嗯，人们现在也这么说英国政治，有人需要站出来说，这一切都是一团糟。这就是我们必须做的，严厉的药物。当然，没错。而且有一种受虐倾向，人们相当喜欢那样。没错。所以，亚历克·道格拉斯-休姆爵士（前首相的兄弟威廉）给《泰晤士报》写了一封可爱的信。他说，是时候选一个不感到羞耻的保守党人了，他会让你买你的劳斯莱斯和雪茄，如果那是你想要的，并把你的儿子送到伊顿公学。如果有人试图对你说“不”，就用倒V字手势向他致意。
So there's this, there's this sort of instinctive, emotional thirst for more robust, more obviously conservative politics. But there's also an intellectual, more ideological side to it. So since 1955, a think tank called the Institute for Economic Affairs has been arguing that Britain has gone much too far down the road to socialism. And it's been calling, like a voice in the wilderness for privatisation of nationalised industries, for colourisation. the welfare state for bringing back free market economics, kind of laissez-faire economics that you would have found in the 19th century under the sort of Gladstone administration and whatnot. And part of this is the adoption of a new creed, which in some ways is quite an old creed, which is monetarism.
所以有一种本能的、情感上的渴望，想要更强硬、更明显的保守派政治。但它也有一个知识性的、更意识形态的一面。所以自1955年以来，一个名为“经济事务研究所”的智库一直在争论，英国在社会主义道路上走得太远了。它一直在呼吁——就像旷野中的声音——私有化国有工业，福利国家，恢复自由市场经济，那种你在19世纪格莱斯顿政府下会发现的自由放任经济等等。而这其中的一部分是采用了一种新的信条，在某些方面也是一种相当古老的信条，即货币主义。
In very simple terms, monetarism is basically the government should stop messing around in the economy, stop taxing and spending, stop worrying about unemployment, just concentrate on the one thing, your one priority, which is regulating the money supply to keep inflation down because inflation is the real evil. And this is the brainchild of the Chicago economist Milton Friedman. He comes to Britain, he gives a lecture about it in 1970. The audience has loads of Tory MPs, also loads of Labour MPs, so Jim Callahan, who will be meeting later in the series, is very interested in this kind of stuff. And by 1974, this message resonates with lots of Tories. they are saying, you know what, we've gone completely wrong.
简单来说，货币主义基本上就是政府应该停止在经济中瞎搞，停止征税和支出，停止担心失业，只专注于一件事，你的首要任务，即调节货币供应以保持低通胀，因为通胀才是真正的邪恶。这是芝加哥经济学家米尔顿·弗里德曼的创意。他来到英国，在1970年发表了一场关于它的演讲。听众中有大量的保守党议员，也有大量的工党议员，所以吉姆·卡拉汉——我们稍后会在系列节目中见到他——对这类事情非常感兴趣。到1974年，这个信息引起了许多保守党人的共鸣。他们说，你知道吗，我们完全错了。
We've been taxing and spending far too much. We've been trying to intervene in the economy and save lame duck industries and stuff. We should just leave the economy alone, stop spending so much money, just worry about inflation. And not worry about unemployment. Exactly, not worry about unemployment. The person who'd really made himself the champion of this with Sir Keith Joseph, but he's now out of the ring and it falls to Thatcher. And his supporters right to Thatcher, but she's very clever about how she's, packages this because her campaign is as much about what we would now call vibes as it is about
我们征税和支出太多了。我们一直试图干预经济，拯救那些“跛脚鸭”工业之类的。我们应该让经济顺其自然，停止花费那么多钱，只担心通胀。而不担心失业。没错，不担心失业。真正使自己成为这一主张拥护者的人是基思·约瑟夫爵士，但他现在已经出局了，这落到了撒切尔身上。他的支持者写信给撒切尔，但她在包装这一点上非常聪明，因为她的竞选活动既关乎我们现在所说的“氛围”，也关乎
ideas. So, first of all, the fact that she's a woman is really important. She basically markets herself as the champion of the middle class housewife, who's basically the person who does the shopping and has to worry about the family budget. She is also, you know, you talked about the role she plays, she is presenting herself as the housewife who will sort out the national budget. Yes, exactly. Balance the books, not spend too much on the shopping or whatever. So it actually ticks two boxes. On the one hand, she says, I'm like voters.
想法。所以，首先，她是女性这一事实非常重要。她基本上把自己推销为中产阶级家庭主妇的拥护者，而这基本上就是那个负责购物、必须为家庭预算操心的人。她也是，你知道，你谈到了她扮演的角色，她把自己表现为将要整理国家预算的家庭主妇。是的，没错。平衡账目，不在购物上花太多钱之类的。所以它实际上勾选了两个框。一方面，她说，我像选民一样。
I'm normal. I'm ordinary. I'm not a, you know, I am a career politician, but I'm kind of not because I'm also a wife and mother. And on the other hand, as you say, means that she can talk about complicated economic issues in very domestic terms. It gives her the kind of tools to do it. So an interview with the mirror before the first ballot. I'm a very ordinary person who leads a very normal life.
我很普通。我过着非常正常的生活。我是一个职业政客，但我又不是，因为我同时也是妻子和母亲。另一方面，正如你所说，这意味着她可以用非常家庭化的术语来谈论复杂的经济问题。这给了她这样做的工具。所以，在第一轮投票前接受《镜报》采访时说：“我是一个非常普通的人，过着非常正常的生活。”
I enjoy it, seeing that the family have a good breakfast, and shopping keeps me in touch. She knows the price of a pint of milk. Exactly. She actually gets the mirror, journalist and photographer, to come and watch her do the housework. Oh, she wears a kind of frilly pinny, doesn't she? Yes, she literally does the housework,
“我喜欢它，确保家人有一顿丰盛的早餐，购物让我保持与现实的联系。”她知道一品脱牛奶的价格。没错。她实际上让《镜报》的记者和摄影师来看她做家务。哦，她穿了一种带褶边的围裙，对吧？是的，她真的在做家务，
and the piece says, you know, she did this, she did the shopping, she did the laundry, and after that she had to tidy up the Tory party, polish off Ted Heath and give Britain a good spring clean. With Margaret Thatcher, it's sometimes a bit hard to tell whether she wants to be Prime Minister or Housewife of the Year. And that, of course, is a very useful car to play if you're pitching yourself as the outsider who's going to clean things up. Now, ironically, the Guardian of all newspapers said that she was all image and no substance. Well, they've changed their mind on that, but they?
文章说，你知道，她做了这个，她去购物，她洗了衣服，在那之后她必须整理保守党，清理掉泰德·希思，给英国来一次彻底的大扫除。对于玛格丽特·撒切尔，有时很难说她到底是想成为首相还是“年度家庭主妇”。当然，如果你把自己定位为要清理一切的局外人，那是一张非常有用的牌。现在，讽刺的是，《卫报》竟然说她只有形象没有实质。嗯，他们改变了对这一点的看法，不是吗？
They did change their mind on that. But actually, that's not right. There is clearly substance there. All her interviews and all her articles and stuff. She says she stands for traditional middle-class, Tory politics. Individual freedom, individual prosperity, law and order, private property, all of this kind of thing. Now, whenever Heath and his camp read this, they kind of wince and laugh. They say, she's selfish, she'd make us narrow-minded, she'd make us too middle class.
他们确实改变了看法。但实际上，那是不对的。那里显然有实质内容。她所有的采访、文章之类的。她说她代表传统的、中产阶级的保守党政治。个人自由、个人繁荣、法律与秩序、私有财产，所有这些东西。现在，每当希思和他的阵营读到这些时，他们都会畏缩并嘲笑。他们说，她很自私，她会让我们变得狭隘，她会让我们变得太中产阶级。
So one of Heath's aides was a young MP called Douglas Hurd, who goes on to be one of Mrs Thatcher's most reliable. ministers. And he said at the time to the journalist Hugo Young, he said she can never win. She's limited by her narrow horizons, no vision, no broad sweep and inability to put herself in other's shoes. So he is fabulously posh, isn't he? He's eaten, foreign office, all of that. But in the long run, when Mr. Satcher resigns and he runs to succeed her, he feels obliged to court the votes of the Tory MPs by affecting to be a tenant farmer, which is a ludicrous pretension. Yeah, exactly, exactly. So it's a sign of how profoundly Mrs. Thatcher is going to upend the kind of social standards
所以希思的一位助手是一位年轻的议员，名叫道格拉斯·赫德，他后来成为撒切尔夫人最可靠的部长之一。他在当时对记者雨果·杨说，他说她永远不会赢。她受限于狭隘的视野，没有远见，没有广阔的胸怀，无法设身处地为他人着想。所以他非常时髦，不是吗？他是伊顿公学毕业的，外交部，所有这些。但从长远来看，当撒切尔夫人辞职，他竞选接替她时，他觉得有义务通过假装自己是一个佃农来争取保守党议员的选票，这是一种荒谬的虚伪。是的，没错，没错。所以这标志着撒切尔夫人将如何深刻地颠覆保守党的社会标准。
of the Conservatives. Completely. And it never occurs to, I guess, people like Douglas Heard in 1975 or the other people around him in Ted Heath's court. You know, they think they are the Tory party. But actually, the Tory party, more broad. activists, voters are much more like Margaret Thatcher than they are like Douglas Hurd. Well, there are more middle class people than there are upper class people.
完全正确。而且我想，1975年的道格拉斯·赫德或泰德·希思圈子里的其他人从来没有想到过这一点。你知道，他们认为他们就是保守党。但实际上，保守党，更广泛的活动家、选民比道格拉斯·赫德更像玛格丽特·撒切尔。嗯，中产阶级的人比上层阶级的人多。
Exactly. Most people, even in the Tory party, didn't go to Eaton. So this is going to be a problem. So anyway, we come to the first ballot, which is Tuesday, the 4th of February, 1975. Of course, everybody knows that Heath will win. Every Tory paper predicts that Heath will win, and only one Tory paper, the mail, explicitly supports Thatcher. There's a good omen for Heath as well.
没错。大多数人，即使在保守党内，也没有上过伊顿公学。所以这将是一个问题。总之，我们来到第一轮投票，1975年2月4日星期二。当然，每个人都知道希思会赢。每一份保守党报纸都预测希思会赢，只有一份保守党报纸，《每日邮报》，明确支持撒切尔。这对希思来说也是一个好兆头。
The gods are with him. Because in that morning's times, Madame Tessauds, the waxworks, have published the result of their annual visitors survey. And in the list of political heroes of visitors to Madam Toswords, Heath has come second. And he's been beaten.
神站在他这一边。因为在当天早上的《泰晤士报》上，杜莎夫人蜡像馆公布了他们年度游客调查的结果。在杜莎夫人蜡像馆游客的政治英雄名单中，希思排在第二位。而且他被击败了。
Only one man has the power to beat Ted Heath. And that man is Henry Kissinger. I mean, Henry Kissinger, very dodgy behavior in, Southeast Asia. But Edward Heath, he abolished all the counties, traditional counties. So what's wrong with the British people voting for that? Yeah. Mad. Why is Heath so high? That's unbelievable. But I mean, his there. So when you filled in this survey when you went to to Madden to the Swords, you had to say who your hero was, but also you had to name people who
只有一个人有能力击败泰德·希思。那个人就是亨利·基辛格。我的意思是，亨利·基辛格，在东南亚的行为非常可疑。但爱德华·希思，他废除了所有的郡，传统的郡。所以英国人民投票支持那个有什么错？是的。疯了。为什么希思排名这么高？这令人难以置信。但我的意思是，他在那里。所以当你去杜莎夫人蜡像馆填写这份调查时，你必须说谁是你的英雄，但也必须列出那些
inspire hate and fear. I love this. So in third place, Richard Nixon. Weird that Kissinger is in one list and Nixon the other. I think there have people. have got that wrong. Second, Adolf Hitler. I mean, he's a bad man. I don't think we can argue with his placing, though I think he should be first because of first place is Harold Wilson. Oh, really? Do you think Howard Wilson was a worse man than Hitler? Sure. No. No, because, well, I mean, the point of comparison, they both like wearing very tight shorts, didn't they? I knew that one come up. I absolutely need. Also, Hitler ran a tighter ship in his bunker than Wilson did in Downing Street.
激发仇恨和恐惧的人。我喜欢这个。所以排在第三位的是理查德·尼克松。奇怪的是基辛格在一个名单上，而尼克松在另一个。我想人们搞错了。第二，阿道夫·希特勒。我的意思是，他是个坏人。我不认为我们可以争论他的排名，尽管我认为他应该是第一，因为第一名是哈罗德·威尔逊。哦，真的吗？你认为哈罗德·威尔逊是一个比希特勒更坏的人吗？当然。不。不，因为，嗯，我的意思是，比较的重点是，他们都喜欢穿非常紧的短裤，不是吗？我知道那个会出来。我绝对需要。而且，希特勒在地堡里管理的秩序比威尔逊在唐宁街管理的要严密。
There's none of the nonsense about lunch. Well, listen, Dominic, we're spiralling off. I think Wilson doesn't belong in that list. I agree with you. I think Hitler is worse than Wilson. Yeah, right. Well, anyway, this is the omen for Heath. He's done well in this poll, so it's looking good.
没有关于午餐的废话。嗯，听着，多米尼克，我们跑题了。我认为威尔逊不属于那个名单。我同意你的看法。我认为希特勒比威尔逊更坏。是的，没错。好吧，总之，这就是希思的预兆。他在这次民意调查中表现不错，所以看起来不错。
The vote is held in committee room 14 in the House of Commons. Heath votes at 3 o'clock and then he goes back to his office to wait with his cronies and his campaign manager Tim Kitson goes off to get the final figures. The suspense mounts. They're all sitting there. kind of glacial and brooding as he always is. Then the door opens and Kitson comes back in. And it's terrible news.
投票在下议院的14号委员会会议室举行。希思在3点投票，然后他回到办公室和他的亲信们等待，他的竞选经理蒂姆·基特森去获取最终数据。悬念加剧。他们都坐在那里。像他一贯那样冷漠和沉思。然后门开了，基特森回来了。这是个可怕的消息。
Heath has won 119 votes. And Thatcher, the Philly, has won 130. They can't believe it. Heath's mate Lord Halesham burst into tears. But it's lucky that Edward Heath is going to take it well, isn't he? Yeah, well, he doesn't give anything away. He's totally impassive. I mean, he's always impassive.
希思赢得了119票。而撒切尔，“小母马”，赢得了130票。他们简直不敢相信。希思的朋友黑尔舍姆勋爵泪流满面。但幸运的是，爱德华·希思会坦然接受，不是吗？是的，好吧，他没有表现出任何东西。他完全不动声色。我的意思是，他总是不动声色。
He just pours himself a massive glass of whiskey. and just sort of sits there like an Easter Island statue. Now in the Thatcher camp there's a mood of absolute amazement and jubilation so they're in Airy Neves flat in Westminster. You can see the footage online on YouTube there's an ITV reporter interviewing Dennis Thatcher
他只是给自己倒了一大杯威士忌，然后就像复活节岛的雕像一样坐在那里。现在在撒切尔阵营，有一种极度惊讶和欢欣鼓舞的气氛，所以他们在艾里·尼夫在威斯敏斯特的公寓里。你可以在YouTube上在线看到这段录像，有一位ITV记者在采访丹尼斯·撒切尔，
saying how do you feel about it? She says, delighted, terribly proud, wouldn't you? Dennis can't believe it. Thatcher's very gracious actually. She says she's very sad for Ted Heath He's had an enormous achievement to be Tory leader so long the woman was thank and applaud him for it
说你对此感觉如何？她说，很高兴，非常自豪，难道你不吗？丹尼斯简直不敢相信。撒切尔实际上非常大度。她说她为泰德·希思感到非常难过，他作为保守党领袖这么久是一个巨大的成就，那个女人感谢并赞扬了他。
but she then says well I haven't won yet because there's got to be a second round when other tourists will pile him interestingly the assumption particularly in Downing Street we haven't mentioned the Labour government at all they think she won't win so Harold Wilson says to his aides he fears Thatcher
但她随后说，好吧，我还没赢，因为还得有第二轮投票，届时其他候选人会加入竞争。有趣的是，当时人们的假设，特别是在唐宁街——我们还没提到工党政府——他们认为她赢不了。所以哈罗德·威尔逊对他的助手说，他担心撒切尔。
especially as a woman because it'll be hard to know how to argue with her you don't want to look like you're being patronising But he says The Conservative Party won't be willing to have her as leader And Willie White Law will win on the second ballot So the second ballot's a week later And now Willie White Law is in the ring
尤其是作为一个女人，因为很难知道该如何与她争论，你不想看起来像是在居高临下。但他又说，保守党不会愿意让她担任领袖，威利·怀特劳会在第二轮投票中获胜。所以第二轮投票在一周后举行，现在威利·怀特劳也加入了竞争。
And Willie White Law is your absolute textbook Casting Agency supplied 1970s Tory politician, isn't he? It's got oyster eyes, hasn't he? Yeah, he's got massive bags under his eyes I mean the bags under his eyes are bigger than his eyes Great ruddy cheeks Yeah, he's a big man.
威利·怀特劳绝对是教科书式的、由选角公司提供的1970年代保守党政客形象，不是吗？他有牡蛎般的眼睛，对吧？是的，他眼袋很大。我是说他的眼袋比眼睛还大。红润的大脸颊。是的，他是个大块头。
He's from the Scottish landed gentry. He went to Winchester. He went to Trinity College, Cambridge. He was a tank commander in Normandy. He led his battalion all the way into Germany. Because this is something we talked about in our 1974 episode, that all these politicians, you know, they can be very fat, they can be very spindly. They all wear thick kind of glasses.
他来自苏格兰地主绅士阶层。他上过温切斯特公学，去过剑桥大学三一学院。他在诺曼底当过坦克指挥官，一路带领他的营打进了德国。因为这是我们在1974年那期节目中讨论过的事情，所有这些政客，你知道，他们可能很胖，也可能很瘦弱，他们都戴着那种厚厚的眼镜。
But they had all been insanely brave in the war and taken out, kind of panzer divisions with single-handedly and things. Storm beaches. They combine an absolutely jaw-dropping resume between 1939 and 1945 with then a 20-year record of sort of shambling incompetence. Yeah. Whiskey. Ill-fitting suits.
但他们在战争中都极其勇敢，曾单枪匹马摧毁过装甲师之类的东西，强攻过海滩。他们将1939年到1945年间令人瞠目结舌的履历，与随后20年那种步履蹒跚的无能记录结合在了一起。是的。威士忌。不合身的西装。
Yeah. Useless legislation. Yeah. Exactly. And he's been leader of the House of Commons for Heath. He was the first ever Northern Ireland secretary. Basically, he was Britain's pro-consul in Belfast. and then he handled the minor strike in 1974.
是的。无用的立法。是的。没错。他曾担任希思政府的下议院领袖。他是史上第一位北爱尔兰事务大臣。基本上，他就是英国在贝尔法斯特的总督，后来他还处理了1974年的矿工罢工。
He's been basically the go-to man for Heath's Tory government. And he's very shrewd, he's very experienced, he's very kind of affable, but he has this shambling and sort of woolly consensus man, Blamange image. For years, everyone had thought he would be Tory leader. He'd been the future England captain of Tories. But because he's been so loyal to Heath for so long,
他基本上是希思保守党政府的得力干将。他非常精明，非常有经验，也非常和蔼可亲，但他有一种步履蹒跚、思维模糊的共识派形象，像布朗芒吉布丁一样。多年来，每个人都认为他会成为保守党领袖。他曾是保守党未来的英格兰队长。但因为他长期以来对希思如此忠诚，
he now enters with a massive handicap because he looks like a coward compared to Thatcher. Thatcher dared to challenge Heath and he didn't. Which is ironic, because of course he's not a coward at all. His record, exactly, given his record of bravery. As the Telegraph says, it looks as though a herd of faint hearts left it to a courageous and able woman to topple a formidable leader and then ganged up to deny her just reward.
他现在带着巨大的劣势入场，因为与撒切尔相比，他看起来像个懦夫。撒切尔敢于挑战希思，而他没有。这很讽刺，因为他当然一点也不懦夫。正如《每日电讯报》所说，看起来就像一群胆小鬼把推翻一位强大领袖的任务留给了一位勇敢而能干的女性，然后又联合起来剥夺她应得的奖励。
And so here we see how get taking on the image of Boeotasia, which will also be a crucial one. Exactly. Well, as one Tory MP said, the choice between Thatcher and White Law is a choice between a woman and an old woman and I will vote for the woman, you know, because he's seen as bumbling and all of this kind of thing. So the vote is held on Tuesday, the 11th of February, and the result comes through at 4 o'clock. Thatcher has won 146 votes. White Law has won 79. The others who've all thrown their hats
所以在这里我们看到了这种形象是如何形成的，这也将是至关重要的一点。没错。正如一位保守党议员所说，在撒切尔和怀特劳之间做选择，是在一个女人和一个老太婆之间做选择，我会投票给那个女人，你知道，因为他被视为笨手笨脚之类的。所以投票在2月11日星期二举行，结果在4点钟公布。撒切尔赢得了146票，怀特劳赢得了79票。其他所有加入竞争的人
in the ring are on dribs and drabs. And unbelievably, something that no one expected, even, you know, a couple of weeks ago, Margaret Thatcher is the leader of the Conservative Party. White law is dumbstruck by this. He burst into tears when he heard the news, and he said later, the worst thing was that his elderly mother could never forgive him for losing to a woman,
都只得了零星几票。令人难以置信的是，即使在几周前，也没有人预料到这一点，玛格丽特·撒切尔成为了保守党领袖。怀特劳对此目瞪口呆。他听到消息时泪流满面，后来他说，最糟糕的是他年迈的母亲永远无法原谅他输给了一个女人，
which tells its own story. Most of the sort of grandees in the Tory party were absolutely appalled, as one party vice chairman put it, my God, the bitch has won. And a lot of young MPs, because a lot of people who join the Tory party, Party is kind of rising stars at this point are Heath people. They're paternalists. They think that to be
这本身就说明了一切。保守党内的大多数权贵都感到非常震惊，正如一位党副主席所说，天哪，那个婊子赢了。许多年轻的议员，因为当时加入保守党作为后起之秀的很多人都是希思的人。他们是家长式统治者。他们认为要
modern is to be, you know, more on the left of the party, I guess. A lot of these people who end up becoming her ministers in the 1980s are really shocked when she wins in 75. People like Kenneth Clark or Norman Fowler or Paul Channon, who was the transport secretary in the 80s. He said at the time, she's a right-wing fanatic who could never win over the middle ground. And what's the reaction of labour to her victory. They think it's a tremendous laugh. So Marcia Williams, great to have her back on the show, Harold Wilson's tyrannical secretary.
现代化就得是，你知道，更偏向党内左翼，我想。很多在80年代成为她内阁大臣的人，在75年她获胜时都感到非常震惊。像肯尼斯·克拉克、诺曼·福勒或保罗·香农（80年代的交通大臣）这样的人。他当时说，她是个右翼狂热分子，永远无法赢得中间派的支持。工党对她的胜利有什么反应？他们觉得这简直是个天大的笑话。所以玛莎·威廉姆斯——很高兴她回到节目中——哈罗德·威尔逊那位专横的秘书，
She later remembered seeing all the ministers laughing and slapping each other on her back and saying, well, the next elections, we're as good as won it. It's a foregone conclusion. This mad woman will never win. Wilson herself was very miserable. He said, oh, I have to learn new tricks to beat a woman. And then characteristically, he poured himself a stiff, Brandy, which he will be doing a lot in this series.
她后来回忆说，看到所有大臣都在大笑，互相拍着背说，好吧，下届选举我们赢定了。这是板上钉钉的事。这个疯女人永远赢不了。威尔逊本人非常痛苦。他说，哦，我得学习新花招来打败一个女人。然后，他一如既往地给自己倒了一杯烈性白兰地，他在这个系列节目中会经常这么做。
But actually the most interesting one is the one prominent Labor woman was a politician called Barbara Castle, who had been in charge of the relations with the trade unions in the late 60s, and had also been Transport Secretary and introduced, I think the seatbelt is Barbara Castle's great innovation. And a lot of people had said of Barbara Castle, maybe she will be the first woman Prime Minister, because she's a sort of real socialist firebrand. And her politics are completely different from Thatcher's. But she writes in her diary,
但实际上最有趣的是一位著名的工党女性，一位名叫芭芭拉·卡索的政客，她在60年代末负责与工会的关系，也曾担任交通大臣，并引入了——我想安全带就是芭芭拉·卡索的伟大创新。很多人曾说芭芭拉·卡索也许会成为第一位女首相，因为她是一个真正的社会主义煽动者。她的政治主张与撒切尔完全不同。但她在日记中写道，
I've had a growing conviction that this would happen. She's so clearly the best man among them. I can't help feeling a thrill, even though I believe her election will make things much more difficult for us. I've been saying for a long time that this country is ready, even more than ready, for a woman prime minister. And of course she's right. Actually, to me, the most surprising thing is Thatcher's reaction.
我越来越确信这会发生。她是他们中间最出色的人，这显而易见。我不禁感到一阵激动，尽管我相信她的当选会让我们处境更加艰难。我早就说过，这个国家已经准备好，甚至不仅仅是准备好，迎接一位女首相了。当然她是正确的。实际上，对我来说，最令人惊讶的是撒切尔的反应。
Because if you go online, you can see her interview with Michael Cockrell of the BBC. And he says, how do you feel? So she's just one. She's in the flush of victory. And she says, it's a sign of the sort of the human being behind the sort of iconic image. She says, to think that one is the next name after a long line of very, very distinguished names. Because my goodness, Edward Heath, Alec Douglas Home, Harold McMillan, Anthony Eden. And then, of course, the great Winston. It's like a dream, really. Wouldn't you think so? I almost webbed. when they told me. I did weep. Yeah, this is the style that basically her admirers adore and her critics
因为如果你上网，你可以看到她接受BBC迈克尔·科克雷尔采访的视频。他问，你感觉如何？她刚刚获胜，正处于胜利的喜悦中。她说，这标志着标志性形象背后的人性一面。她说，想到自己是继一长串非常、非常杰出的名字之后的下一个名字。因为天哪，爱德华·希思、亚历克·道格拉斯-霍姆、哈罗德·麦克米伦、安东尼·艾登。然后，当然，伟大的温斯顿。这真的像一场梦。你不觉得吗？他们告诉我的时候，我差点哭了。我确实哭了。是的，这就是她崇拜者所喜爱而批评者
loathe. This sort of slightly syrupy. She's very good at this, this sort of stuff. So, she's another Tory leader. Just as we, I know this has been a very long episode, but just a couple of things
所厌恶的风格。这种略带甜腻的感觉。她很擅长这个，这种东西。所以，她是另一位保守党领袖。正如我们——我知道这一集很长，但还有几件事
about what it actually means. Afterwards, a lot of people said, it was a fluke that basically history could have worked out in lots of different ways. You know, Ted Heath could have resigned earlier. somebody else could have stood against him. Keith Joseph might not have made that mad speech,
关于它实际意味着什么。事后，很多人说，这纯属侥幸，历史本可以有许多不同的走向。你知道，泰德·希思本可以早点辞职，其他人本可以站出来反对他，基思·约瑟夫可能不会发表那次疯狂的演讲，
and then she'd never have stood, which is sort of true. You know, there are ways in which history could turn out differently, but there are definitely deeper factors. So just to whiz through some of the deeper factors. It's interesting when you look at the vote. The Tory MPs who voted for Heath
那么她就永远不会参选，这在某种程度上是真的。你知道，历史确实有不同的走向，但肯定有更深层次的因素。让我们快速浏览一下这些深层因素。看看投票结果很有趣。投票给希思的保守党议员
tend to be public schoolboys, landed gentry, MPs from Scotland and Wales. Do you know who they're like? They are. They're Rory Stewart. Yes. That's his constituency. and her supporters are more likely to come from the south of England to have gone to grammar schools, not public schools, so they're more middle class, less posh.
往往是公立学校出身、地主绅士、来自苏格兰和威尔士的议员。你知道他们像谁吗？他们是罗里·斯图尔特。是的，那是他的选区。而她的支持者更有可能来自英格兰南部，上过文法学校，而不是公立学校，所以他们更中产阶级，没那么势利。
They're Essex men. Yes, they're on the right of the party. So like Norman Tebitt. Exactly. Who I think he is an MP at this point, is he? Yes. He's called the Skinhead, isn't he? They're Chingford Skinhead.
他们是埃塞克斯人。是的，他们属于党内右翼。比如诺曼·泰比特。没错。我想他当时已经是议员了，对吧？是的。他被称为“光头党”，不是吗？他们是青福德的光头党。
Chingford Skinhead. Exactly. They are more, they're self-made, their politics are more aggressive, their politics are more, They would say no doubt, we are true Tories, and these poshos are actually just weak. Yeah. So it's estate agents, not owners of estates. Exactly. Estate agents have taken over from the estate owners.
青福德光头党。没错。他们更……他们是白手起家，他们的政治主张更激进，他们的政治主张更……他们无疑会说，我们才是真正的保守党人，而这些势利小人其实只是软弱。是的。所以是房地产经纪人，而不是地产所有者。没错。房地产经纪人取代了地产所有者。
They're aspirational. They've worked for their success, and they don't feel guilty about it. So there's a class element. There's an ideological element, which is the resurgence of this free market liberal tradition that has been underplayed since 1945 because the post-war Tory leaders, have been so keen to banish memories of the Depression. And her critics, sort of on the left of the Tory party, like Serian Gilmore, who wrote a book about it,
他们有抱负。他们通过努力获得了成功，并且对此并不感到内疚。所以有一个阶级因素。还有一个意识形态因素，那就是自1945年以来一直被低估的自由市场自由主义传统的复兴，因为战后的保守党领袖们太急于抹去对大萧条的记忆。而她那些保守党左翼的批评者，比如写过相关书籍的塞里安·吉尔莫，
in the 80s, said, she's actually not really a conservative. She's not a proper conservative. She's that most hideous of things, a Gladstonean liberal who believes in free markets and all of this. And I think this is actually, I think this is rubbish. I think free market liberalism had always been part of the Tory brand. And, you know, everything that she's saying, Baldwin and Chamberlain and Disraeli, I mean, I don't think they'd have really argued with all this stuff about, you know, low taxes, you know, standing in her own two feet, blah, blah, blah, blah.
在80年代说，她其实并不是真正的保守党人。她不是一个正统的保守党人。她是那种最可怕的东西，一个相信自由市场等等的格莱斯顿式自由主义者。我认为这其实是胡说八道。我认为自由市场自由主义一直是保守党品牌的一部分。而且，你知道，她所说的一切，鲍德温、张伯伦和迪斯雷利，我的意思是，我不认为他们会反对所有关于低税收、自力更生等等的说法。
I think it's actually the heathai period that's the aberration rather than the Thatcherite one. But the two things that I think are really distinctive about thatterism. First of all, I think it has a big populist element to it. And that housewife thing that we mentioned is a big part of it. Grantham is a big part of it, the grocer's shop, the grammar school. A lot of things that she had once tried to leave behind, because they're not really, she wanted to be more respectable, but now she glories in them.
我认为其实希思时期才是反常的，而不是撒切尔时期。但我认为撒切尔主义有两个真正独特的地方。首先，我认为它有一个很大的民粹主义元素。我们提到的那个“家庭主妇”形象是其中的重要部分。格兰瑟姆是重要部分，杂货店，文法学校。很多她曾经试图抛弃的东西，因为它们不够体面，但现在她以此为荣。
They're very useful to her. So she boasts, I mean, here's an interview she gives a world in action. She says, they say, where do your values come from? She says, well, they come from my life experience. From going to an ordinary state school, having no privileges at all, except perhaps the ones that count most. A good home background
它们对她非常有用。所以她吹嘘——这是她接受《世界在行动》采访时说的。她说，他们问，你的价值观从何而来？她说，好吧，它们来自我的人生经历。来自上普通的公立学校，没有任何特权，除了也许是最重要的那些。良好的家庭背景，
with parents who are very interested in their children and in them getting on. And all of this thing, she says again and again, I'm a plain, straightforward provincial. I've got no hang-ups about my background. I know what it's like running a house. I know what it's like having to live within a budget. I know what it's like having to cope.
父母非常关心他们的孩子，关心他们的进步。所有这些，她一遍又一遍地说，我是一个朴实、直率的乡下人。我对我的背景没有任何心理负担。我知道经营一个家是什么感觉。我知道在预算内生活是什么感觉。我知道如何应对困难。
No Tory leader before her could have said this. If Harold McMillan had said this, people would have laughed at him. Yeah, Winston Churchill. Yeah, he's not going to say that. But it's so influential that then you get Douglas Heard pretending to be a tenant farmer and, you know, Kemi Bates not going on about how she worked in McDonald's and things. I mean, it's absolutely what you have to do now. It's a political star that had long been very popular in America, but not in Britain, I would say. The other thing is something else you get some Grantham, and that's the Methodism.
在她之前的保守党领袖没人能说出这话。如果哈罗德·麦克米伦这么说，人们会嘲笑他。是的，温斯顿·丘吉尔。是的，他不会那么说。但这太有影响力了，以至于后来道格拉斯·赫德假装自己是佃农，还有凯米·巴德诺赫谈论她在麦当劳工作之类的。我的意思是，这绝对是你现在必须做的。这是一种在美洲早已非常流行，但在英国并不流行的政治风格。另一件事是来自格兰瑟姆的另一样东西，那就是卫理公会教派。
And actually this to me, I think this is one of the absolute defining things of Thatcherism. It's the tone, the moralistic, evangelical tone. Yeah, and the low church tone rather than the high church tone. Completely. Margaret Roberts, as a girl, had to say grace before every meal. She had to go to chapel three or four times on Sundays. Her father as a lay preacher went on and on and on about hard work, individualism, thrift, clean living, all of this. And this is what I think makes her politics different.
实际上，对我来说，我认为这是撒切尔主义最核心的定义之一。那就是语调，那种道德主义的、福音派的语调。是的，是低教会派的语调，而不是高教会派的语调。完全正确。玛格丽特·罗伯茨小时候每顿饭前都要做祷告。她周日必须去教堂三四次。她父亲作为一名平信徒传教士，不断地谈论努力工作、个人主义、节俭、清廉的生活，所有这些。这就是我认为让她的政治主张与众不同的地方。
There is a moralism to it, a low church moralism, that is totally unlike anything that any other Tory leader says before. So in 1984, an interview with the Times, I am in politics because of the conflict between good and evil, and I believe that in the end, good will triumph. I mean, Ted Heath could have lived to the age of 10,000, and he would never have said anything like that. It's unthinkable. Also, I mean, what's interesting is that it's giving to the left what the left often give to the right. It's casting the left as evil and the right as virtuous. And usually it's the other way around. Completely it is. I mean, you see this reflected in her archives, which are online at the Thatcher Foundation website, which is brilliant, by the way, this amazing digital archive. You can see all the notes that she would handwrite for her conference speeches, and they'd be full of all the stuff about, you know, the evils of socialism, good versus evil, what the great religions of the past teach us, what life, you know, life is struggle. Her speechwriters would cut all this. They'd say, God, this is bonkers. But it would find its way in. one way or another. And I think you're absolutely right. She thinks socialism is not just wrong. She thinks it's morally, it's evil. It's corrupting. And people in 70s Britain, you know, they're used to
它有一种道德主义，一种低教会派的道德主义，这与任何其他保守党领袖之前的言论完全不同。所以在1984年接受《泰晤士报》采访时，她说，我投身政治是因为善与恶之间的冲突，我相信最终善会战胜恶。我的意思是，泰德·希思就算活到一万岁，也永远不会说出那样的话。这简直不可思议。而且，有趣的是，她把左翼通常给右翼的东西给了左翼。她把左翼描绘成邪恶的，把右翼描绘成正义的。通常情况正好相反。完全是这样。我的意思是，你在她的档案中可以看到这一点，这些档案在撒切尔基金会网站上，顺便说一句，那个数字档案非常棒。你可以看到她为会议演讲手写的所有笔记，里面充满了关于社会主义的邪恶、善与恶、过去伟大宗教教导我们什么、生活是斗争等等的内容。她的演讲稿撰写人会删掉所有这些。他们会说，天哪，这太疯狂了。但它总会以某种方式出现在演讲中。我认为你是完全正确的。她认为社会主义不仅是错误的，她认为它在道德上是邪恶的。它是腐蚀性的。而70年代英国的人们，你知道，他们习惯于
thinking socialists are well-meaning and idealistic. Maybe they're a bit deluded, but blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, well, she doesn't think that. She doesn't think they are well-meaning idealistic. She thinks that they're doing the devil's work. Yeah. And that's what makes for her admirers, it's so invigorating and for her critics. I mean, if you're on the left, right, and you're used to thinking yourself of yourself as the goodies, to be told, actually, you're the bad people. It's insulting.
认为社会主义者是善意和理想主义的。也许他们有点被误导了，但等等等等，好吧，她不这么认为。她不认为他们是善意和理想主义的。她认为他们在做魔鬼的工作。是的。这就是为什么对她的崇拜者来说，这让人振奋；而对她的批评者来说——我的意思是，如果你是左翼，习惯于认为自己是好人，却被告知其实你是坏人，这是一种侮辱。
And it's why I think one reason why people take it so personally when she sort of wades into battle. And talking of people taking it personally, what about Edward Heath, aka the incredible? the incredible sulk. So the day after she won, she went to see Heath in Belgravia at his house. And she said, you know, it's a courtesy call. Ted, would you serve in a senior position under me?
这就是为什么我认为当她投入战斗时，人们会如此针对她个人的原因之一。说到人们针对个人，爱德华·希思，又名“不可思议的家伙”，怎么样？不可思议的生闷气者。所以她获胜后的第二天，她去贝尔格莱维亚的家中拜访希思。她说，你知道，这只是礼节性拜访。泰德，你愿意在我手下担任高级职位吗？
And her aides told the press afterwards that Heath had deliberately stacked books on all the chairs and made it impossible for her to sit down. So he sat down, but she had to reign standing. It says it all about Ted Heath. I mean, if it was anyone else, you wouldn't believe it. but with him it sounds absolutely plausible. And he spoke to Huronian monosyllables.
她的助手后来告诉媒体，希思故意在所有的椅子上堆满了书，让她无法坐下。所以他坐下了，但她不得不站着。这完全说明了泰德·希思的为人。我的意思是，如果是别人，你可能不信，但对他来说，这听起来绝对可信。他用单音节词回答她。
So he just said, no, yes, goodbye, whatever. And he then embarks on this unbelievably spectacular sulk. So at the end of the year, Willie Whitelaw tried to organise a reconciliation, he said. You know, why don't you get together, have a meeting and come together for the good of the party in the country? He said no, and he said to him, Thatcher and her supporters are traitors. they will destroy the party and destroy Britain. Two years after that, another of their friends, Peter Carrington, said to him, I think you should try harder to be a good loser.
所以他只是说，不，是，再见，之类的。然后他开始了这种令人难以置信的壮观的生闷气。所以年底，威利·怀特劳试图组织一次和解，他说，你知道，你们为什么不聚一聚，开个会，为了党和国家的利益团结起来？他说不，并对他说，撒切尔和她的支持者是叛徒，他们会摧毁这个党，摧毁英国。两年后，他们的另一个朋友彼得·卡林顿对他说，我认为你应该努力做一个大度的人。
And I think you should make a real effort now to rehabilitate yourself and go around telling everybody how great you think Margaret Thatcher is. And the wonderful account, he stared at him in a quote, absolute amazement. And said, why on earth where I do that? I don't think she's any good. I'm much better. I should be there still.
我认为你现在应该做出真正的努力来重塑自己，到处告诉大家你认为玛格丽特·撒切尔有多棒。据精彩的描述，他盯着他，引用原话，“绝对的惊讶”。然后说，我为什么要那样做？我不认为她有什么好。我比她强得多。我本该还在那个位置上。
And basically he lives this for the rest of his life. He's still sulking, even after she's kind of stopped being prime minister. Even after she's an elderly woman, Heath is still nursing his hatred. And he will never, ever, ever give it up, which makes, which is very amusing, I have to say. But the thing is, a lot of people agreed with Ted Heath in the 70s. They agreed that he was better and that he should still be there. You know you did that introduction. I mean, that really did capture how she spoke in the Commons
基本上他余生都活在这种状态中。他一直在生闷气，即使在她不再担任首相之后。即使在她是一位老妇人之后，希思仍然怀着他的仇恨。他永远、永远、永远不会放弃，这让我觉得非常有趣。但问题是，70年代很多人同意泰德·希思的观点。他们同意他更出色，他本该还在那个位置上。你知道你做了那个介绍。我的意思是，那确实捕捉到了她在下议院的讲话方式，
when she made her debut as Tory leader. She was, everyone said she was very pale and nervous. She was hesitant or gabbled and then was shrill and just, and Wilson, so the very first PMQs, Wilson drank three glasses of brandy to steady his nerves, then went in and absolutely wiped the floor with her. She was no good at all. And there's a lovely description two months later
当她作为保守党领袖首次亮相时。每个人都说她脸色苍白，非常紧张。她说话犹豫不决，语速很快，然后声音尖锐，而且威尔逊——所以第一次首相问答环节，威尔逊喝了三杯白兰地来稳住神经，然后进去彻底地让她颜面扫地。她一点也不好。两个月后有一个可爱的描述，
by Wilson's aide Bernard Donahue, who wrote a fantastic diary, and we'll be quoting from him a lot in the next few episodes. He said, of Prime Minister's questions, the only interest is to see Margaret Thatcher sitting there petrified, like a rabbit in front of a stote,
来自威尔逊的助手伯纳德·多纳休，他写了一本精彩的日记，我们将在接下来的几集里经常引用他。他说，关于首相问答环节，唯一的看点就是看玛格丽特·撒切尔坐在那里惊恐万状，就像一只面对白鼬的兔子，
and Ted Heath, sitting, waiting stonily in the corner, with no sign of life until Harold puts the boot into Mrs. Thatcher, when a wintry smile crosses his face. So this sets the tone, really, for the next six months. I mean, we talked about Kemi Bajnock and her rocky start as leader of the opposition.
而泰德·希思坐在角落里冷漠地等待着，毫无生气，直到哈罗德给撒切尔夫人致命一击时，他脸上才会露出一丝冷笑。所以这确实为接下来的六个月定下了基调。我的意思是，我们谈到了凯米·巴德诺赫作为反对党领袖的艰难开局。
Thatcher's start is very, very rocky. In the first six months, her approval rating fell by half, from 64% to 35%. And by the summer of 1975, a lot of people are saying she's obviously a mistake. She's a dud. Heath's friend, Lord Carrington, says to his pals, she, you know, mark my words, she will be gone by Christmas. But will she? Because everything is about to change.
撒切尔的开局非常、非常艰难。在最初的六个月里，她的支持率减半，从64%降至35%。到1975年夏天，很多人都在说她显然是个错误。她是个失败者。希思的朋友卡林顿勋爵对他的伙伴们说，她，你知道，记住我的话，她圣诞节前就会下台。但她会吗？因为一切都即将改变。
The economy is heading towards the rocks. Britain is about to hold its first ever referendum on whether to leave the European community. And the Prime Minister Harold Wilson is planning to walk out of British politics at a point when the international money markets are about to lose confidence in Britain as a going concern and to leave Britain teetering on the brink of financial oblivion.
经济正走向崩溃。英国即将举行有史以来第一次关于是否脱离欧洲共同体的公投。而首相哈罗德·威尔逊正计划退出英国政坛，此时国际金融市场正准备对英国作为一家持续经营的企业失去信心，让英国摇摇欲坠地处于金融毁灭的边缘。
God, unbelievable excitements. And on top of that, Dominic, am I not right in saying that you have the sex pistols lurking in the wings? The long hot summer of 1976? Yeah. And I imagine that there'll be all kinds of insane shambolic goings on in Downing Street. So all of that to look forward to. The rest of history, club members of course, can hear the next three episodes right now. Our newsletters, they'll be thudding into your inboxes anytime soon.
天哪，令人难以置信的兴奋。最重要的是，多米尼克，我没说错吧，你还有性手枪乐队潜伏在幕后？1976年漫长而炎热的夏天？是的。我想唐宁街会有各种疯狂混乱的事情发生。所以所有这些都值得期待。历史俱乐部的成员当然可以现在就听到接下来的三集。我们的通讯，很快就会塞进你们的收件箱。
loads of 70s content and if you would like to join the rest of history club and you're not already a member then of course you can go to the rest of history.com and sign up there but in the meanwhile thank you dominic thanks everyone for listening bye bye goodbye goodbye There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有很多70年代的内容，如果你想加入历史俱乐部，而你还不是会员，那么当然你可以去restofhistory.com注册。但与此同时，谢谢你多米尼克，谢谢大家的收听，再见，再见，再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。